Here we go.
Freaks.
I forgot to write that on twitter,
so I'm doing that right now.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm real bad at that to say we're
starting.
Yeah,
well I'm real bad at tweeting right
before we start,
I always forget
and now I'm doing it.
No bitches or does it to Rogan talk?
No,
it's ustream dot TV slash board slash
Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm here all weekend.
I'm here all week except Tuesday.
You're having a conversation in the
middle of a podcast stoner boy.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
was sponsored by squarespace.
Squarespace is an all in one web making
platform,
website making platform on the web.
Um,
squarespace has it set up so that with
the normal skills that people acquire by
using computers like drag and drop and
copy and paste and point and click,
you can do all that shit.
You can make a bad ass professional
looking website.
It literally and figuratively is that
easy.
Um,
squarespace has a bunch of different
beautiful designs for you start with,
you can use your own images.
They offer 24 slash seven support and
you can set up an online store that very
easily you can set up an online store
for music as well if you sell music or
even if you sell comedy,
like if you,
uh,
were selling digital downloads,
they can set that up for you as well.
Um,
squarespace has a new logo creator where
you can create a clean and simple logo
design for yourself in minutes.
Um,
it's really interesting.
I have had nothing but positive feedback
from squarespace.
Anybody that have turned onto it is a,
has,
becomes a huge fan once you start using
it and they're so confident about it
that they allow you to use squarespace
without entering your credit card
information first.
And then when you say,
you know what,
this is fucking awesome.
Then you enter in your credit card
information and then you actually get
charged for it.
So they'll let you try it out and see
what the website would look like.
Um,
it's just really impressive.
we had a contest and we've talked about
this,
but I'll just say it again.
It was really kind of unfair because
there were so many different people made
awesome websites.
To pick four is that we picked four to
pick four,
so it's not.
It's not fair.
There was too many guns.
I met some comics are talking about that
in New York.
They were entering into some cottons of
the contest.
There was too many people that have
awesome websites,
but we picked some wicked ones.
Point is these are not people that have
ever done anything like that before.
There are people that for the most part,
believe for web designers.
I think there were just folks.
I might be wrong about that.
Either way they use squarespace to do it
and you can too.
It's not like they get magic access to
special tools.
A squarespace.
If you there for a free trial and 10
percent off your purchase,
go to squarespace.com
and enter in the code word Joe.
That's squarespace.com
and enter the code word Joe.
A really awesome way to create your own
website.
I couldn't be happier with
squarespace.com.
What he says your.
I love TSA cock.
That's the new new website,
by the way,
that's a website now that's done.
So what Brian did that during the time
that we did that commercial,
he made a website.
It's pretty ridiculous name.
He just puts it in poop.
I'm speaking of websites stamps.
Dot Com is another awesome website that
you can use to stay to save a lot of
bullshit in your life.
Stamps.com
allows you to weigh print way your
packages,
print them with official US postage on a
regular home computer.
Apply it to your package.
Mailman comes,
he handed off to them,
boom.
The rates change.
Stamps.com
has it covered.
If you don't have to worry about God,
I forgot they went up ten cents this
week.
Are you?
It's all in.
They figured it out for you and with
stamps.com,
it takes away all the hassle of waiting
in line,
dealing with someone at the post office
and weighing each individual package.
You could do it all naked and drunk and
the comfort of your own home and nobody
can say shit and it works.
It's a beautiful thing and if you enter
in the code word j r e in that little
microphone in the upper right hand
corner of the old school microphone
entering the Code Word Jr,
he you'll get $110 bonus offer which
includes a digital scale and up to $55
or free postage,
so that stamps.com.
Before you do anything,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in J R,
e stamps.com
is with Brian Red band uses to send
those desk squad dot,
t v t shirts if you're like,
I see these sweet little kitty cat tee
shirts,
but I don't know where to buy them.
It's [inaudible] Dot TV and when you get
them they will be used by stamps.com.
That's all it'll be sent to you.
So think of that bitch stamps.
ICOMP jre were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t a human optimization
website.
We we strive to send you things that
work and send you things that make your
body function better.
What are the ones that keep you up?
Is that,
that doesn't keep you up.
Wake you up,
wake you up.
I think you're thinking,
what are you thinking of when you're
tired for radio?
Are you thinking of like,
um,
like you,
that can do that,
but if you thinking of that,
are you thinking of a drug you think it
was that Joel,
do you know what I'm talking about?
Is that what you're thinking of?
Oh No,
what is that?
That's the stuff that keeps you awake.
That is a prescriber to narcolepsy
people over.
And if you,
uh,
yeah,
and if you're feeling sleepy and you pop
one of those bitches,
it goes away.
Really just totally goes away.
It's been in it.
It gives a soldiers,
I'm sure they give him the soldiers.
They probably eat them like candy and
they throw in steroid apple with all
these holes in it.
Special Apple.
Yeah.
That stuff is uh,
they did some cap difficult for sure.
Probably do some captain America Shit to
soldiers.
I just tried to get new video from my
drug dealer.
He's got to get any pill and I'm like,
all right,
get me nuvigil.
I'm really.
And he's like,
yeah man,
it hasn't hit.
We haven't gotten any of those.
Oh,
he doesn't know what it is.
You can buy it online.
Then.
I know there's a thread.
There's a whole thread on the
underground and really how to buy
provigil online.
Yeah.
Provigil or luke vigil.
Totally legal.
Which one's better?
I told him.
No,
that's a good question.
I've only tried new vigil.
That's what I gave you.
A new visual.
You've got some other stuff too from on
it.
Like Alpha brain one 81 80 is one new
mood powder that you put in a drain.
It gets you more alert.
Yeah,
it's one 80.
That's great.
I love it.
It's this stuff.
It's in these.
Yeah,
they're great.
I'd take the.
Okay.
I gave it to you before.
You drink two of those motherfuckers
before every UFC.
It's great.
Really?
Yes.
Well listen man,
we had alpha brains in those and Alpha
brain is the big one for me.
How long until it kicks in?
Oh,
just like an hour.
So it kicks in well,
it's just nutrients,
you know,
it's not like kick it in like a drug.
It has an effect,
Don your memory.
It has an effect on certain aspects of
your,
uh,
your ability to execute tasks and sit
and chill.
It's for jetlag all nighters,
hangovers and pity parties party on
that.
We're not lying.
Fuck.
That needs nutrients.
We all know people like that.
I'm busy having a pity party says that
on that pity party.
This was a smiley face on the course.
Does.
Why do you think they just didn't have
one next one to put on there?
So they decided,
oh,
let's just throw pity parties.
They didn't have an extra one.
It's just,
that's the perfect thing to have on
there,
right thing.
It's the right thing to say if you have
an API party plan.
I remember just like yelling at you
guys.
And I'm like,
I'm cranky because I'm tired.
Claims that's what's happening right
now.
Yeah,
you gotta learn how to handle that shit.
One of the best ways to handle that shit
is with health.
Second best way.
There were pity party.
If,
uh,
if you take a Alpha brain or if you take
one and you're having a pity party,
but you're also giving yourself some
nutrients,
all pity parties are putting nutrients.
Go in there.
It's a bunch of shit.
I'm in Alpha brain.
It's um,
Alpha brain.
Uh,
we,
we recently got done with the,
uh,
the,
the first results published a clinical
test of a Alpha brain,
double blind placebo tests and showed
positive results.
We printed it all up on [inaudible] dot
com.
The,
um,
the things there for anybody to,
uh,
to go investigate and check it out.
And we're in the middle of a much larger
scale to this was the first one was
something called a pilot test with a
pilot test.
You only use 20 people had a couple,
dropped out,
three dropped out,
I believe.
So I think we were left with 17 or 16.
I can't remember exactly where they just
get lazy up,
just give up they want to do anymore.
But the people that stayed,
that used Alpha brain showed an
improvement.
They showed improvement in memory.
Um,
I,
I don't want to read the things that
don't totally understand how these
things work.
I've had explained it,
explained to me many ways,
but you could view it all.
Anybody who's interested view at all and
view all the ingredients.
We also offer a 100 percent,
90,
90 day 30 pill moneyback guarantee on
Alpha brain or any of the supplements
because they are controversial.
There's plenty of science behind all of
these individual ingredients that we
use,
whether it's an Alpha brain,
whether it's a new mood,
there's evidence along with the study
results along with references.
All those,
everything that we could find about it
that's imperative that people be
educated about.
We have printed up on [inaudible] dot
com.
So if you're interested in it and you're
like,
what is this horseshit?
Is this snake oil?
Be At least relieved in the fact that
there's a 100 percent money back
guarantee in the first 30 pills for 90
days.
You have 100 percent.
You don't have to return the pills.
He just say this stuff didn't work and
you get your money back.
You don't have to send back anything.
Oh really?
Yes.
Because we're not.
I don't want to reuse them.
No one's gonna.
Look at whatever they gonna do the grab
bag.
Yeah.
I'm not going to.
We're not going to destroy it,
but we don't even want,
you know,
we don't.
You could.
The idea behind it is the idea that if
you enjoy something,
like at least I do.
If I enjoy something,
I want to buy it.
That's how I feel like whether it's a
want anybody's money.
I didn't like it anyway.
Exactly,
exactly.
And I'm,
I'm honest about it.
I love this stuff.
I've taken all the time.
If it wasn't for that,
I would.
I get a little nervous if I have to do
something and I don't have it.
They're not that I need it,
but that I know that it has a benefit.
It just does.
Not that I need.
It sounds like a drug addict,
but I'm saying it is very much like a
drug addict.
I'm a drug addict for healthy shit.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You are totally what?
Sure.
Somewhere what's an ideal heart rate
when you're working at a thousand?
Like you don't want to go over 180 is
probably about as high as you ever want
to go.
What are you up to?
One 71 80.
You know,
you're fucking red line and shit on the
clips on their fingers.
Now.
It's like when they have those little
things you put your hands on when you're
working out those accurate.
Yeah,
those are accurate.
You have.
I mean you can go over one 80 about
probably the most anybody ever doesn't
in athletic competition and I would
guess it's probably like in the two
hundreds of like the early 200,
like maybe to 10.
Let's see.
Let's be frightened as people are.
What's the highest?
Yeah.
Because I know there's an ideal heart
rate that you want to just kind of like
coast stat as much as possible and
really that just like shreds through
calories more than.
Right.
You just keep that going.
But I'm also,
I was looking at,
I was looking at the guy next to me and
he tried,
he did his and he was like one 62 and
I'm like,
Oh shit.
You know what's the.
He was about the thought.
I really like him.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
That's died of a heart attack or just he
just dot,
okay,
here's the,
here's your maximum heart rate.
If you're 20 years old,
up to 100.
Seventy pounds is,
um,
it's 200 planes.
Neither of those two things don't.
Wait,
do I just doubled that?
Uh,
I,
I read this incorrectly.
It's not up to 170 pounds.
It doesn't have the pounds factor.
Then it's actually a,
your target rate.
Heart zone is one of them.
And the other one was your predicted
maximum heart rate.
So your target raise between 1:20
and one slash 70 if you're 20 years old.
I just gave it a cursory glance and your
maximum is somewhere around 200.
And as you get older,
your maximum drops and drops and drops.
Yeah.
Well,
you're fucking dying.
That freaks me out.
I guess it goes away.
Well,
you've got to start slow.
Dude.
You haven't been working out.
If you're really going to.
That's one thing that I always stress.
If anybody says,
hey man,
I want to start doing kettlebells,
please.
Whatever you do,
start slow,
get some light weights and just work on
the form and work on getting it down and
then do it so that you can do 15 of
those comfortably.
Then bumped yourself up to 35 pounds.
Then pump yourself up again and you know
x amount of months later,
but do it slowly.
If you do it slowly,
you will get strong like,
everybody's got this idea.
I go to fucking do it all today.
Don't do it all today.
Don't do it slowly.
Work on your form.
Learn the movements and yeah,
it's not going to feel like an
unbelievable workout.
The first,
you know x amount of times you do it,
but ultimately you're going to build up
and you're going to get yourself into a
position where your muscles are
protected to.
You're doing heavy shit and your body's
not used to it.
You want to make sure that your joints
are stable.
You want to make sure that your core is
strong.
You want to take care of all these
different problem areas that the worst
thing that can happen is if you're doing
like a strength and conditioning workout
is you fucking hurt yourself because
then you're just going to get bombed out
about exercise.
You're going to gain more weight.
You're going to have a pity party.
You guys agree with any of this guys,
you're,
you're not in shape.
You need to get in shape right now.
Do it today.
Get it done today.
Reach for the stars.
Don't become like pinette.
Do extra work getting shaped today.
Don't listen to the losers like Joe
Rogan,
who doesn't it
the heart.
They're going through a real workout.
The real problem.
The real problem with all this,
um,
you know,
is that people have to ramp up and
that's what people have a hard time
doing.
You do ultimately have to ramp up,
like you got to start slow,
but yeah,
it's going to be fine in the beginning,
but I'm telling you right now,
it's going to be fucking hell if you do
it right.
If you really want to get in shape,
you're going to have to go through the
fires and if you're not willing to go
through the fires,
you're going to always maintain a
certain level of fitness.
You're never going to get really strong.
You're never going to get really fast.
You're never going to get in good shape.
You got to be able to push yourself but
do it correctly.
But if you do do it,
Goddamn you'll feel better.
Everything will work better.
What did you do that?
Well,
because this is my first time back in
two years,
so I just did 20 minutes on the
elliptical,
but at a high level,
you know,
but so it was like I was climbing a
mountain type thing.
Was your body like,
what the fuck is it got to a point where
my,
my legs felt numb.
Like I felt like,
oh shit,
I can't feel my legs anymore.
I don't want to fall down.
And then I just did the machines where I
started from one machine and we went
through all the machines and did like a
five,
seven minute reps of all of them.
Have all force yourself to do this.
I smelled a battle rope.
They had one there.
Yeah.
I just want to see it with some of those
are battle ropes.
Oh,
I thought those were like tie you up
ropes.
Oh,
Ari,
they look all night.
No,
those are the ones on the far left are
the heavy shipyard ones.
They're pretty dope.
We have a bunch of different weights and
sizes,
but a 40 inch ones or the 50 inch ones.
Men Get their fucking fun.
That's subliminal.
They're like,
yeah,
you got the little.
Might pretty pony rope or do you got
like that mean danger like yellow black.
Pretty pony rope is like,
that's for girls.
Let's be real.
It's for girls and very weak men or
incentive to not,
you know,
not want to use prince's road.
You should make videos of.
People have really scrawny dude's doing
this badly.
Like guys get the reporters from vice
fellows with glasses in there for Doris,
Doris,
but door keeps falling off.
They keep putting it back on workout for
one.
Sylaria a crunchy thing in my goal,
but lost that when I do like the weight
room,
lifting things above my head makes like
a clicking noise in my right elbow.
As long as it doesn't hurt,
don't worry about it.
Probably some shit broken loose in there
from all your years of battling were
leaning on tables.
Yeah.
There's probably some calcium chips.
Um,
this guy,
uh,
that fights in the UFC.
Shocker Ray,
who's a really high level Jujitsu guys,
very famous Jujitsu guy.
He just had all these pieces of meat
removed from his elbow and they took
photos of it.
Pull up the photos of your five,
me a c,
a r e s a elbow surgery and see if you
find images because the images,
they had pictures of the um,
the amount of stuff that they polled far
left far left.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
That was in there.
I was in his elbow.
That was all the stuff that they pulled
out of his elbow.
Corn does,
it looks like garlic and teeth and he,
um,
he fucking won.
Even with all this shit floating around
the elbow.
Let's just,
from years of Jujitsu of getting Armbar,
you're getting chunks of heartland
snapped off,
you know,
that's like the dirty secret when it
comes to,
uh,
whether it's grapplers or Stryker's.
A lot of these guys,
they get to the assert an age and
they're just in pain and what are the.
Just fill in the pieces that were,
that came off.
They just break off.
There's nothing there anymore.
It's just more a mean.
Your cartilage gets damaged,
you know,
or whatever that is.
Bone Spurs,
whatever it is.
But it's a real good saga.
It's a common thing with a lot of guys.
A lot of guys get a elbow injuries and
knee injuries for big chunks of a
meniscus or removed from your legs.
This is a weird doesn't.
If it doesn't hurt,
don't worry about it,
man.
I'm telling you,
if it doesn't hurt,
it's just nonsense.
What if it's going to go into your
bloodstream so they could die?
It could die.
They clog up your brain.
If it went through that you could die.
Let's go to [inaudible] dot com and use
the cardboard Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any supplements.
Still sponsor it must be.
We haven't never done the music on it,
so let's just do the music part.
No,
no.
All right.
Experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Oh,
sweet baby.
Jesus already should fear fresh off of a
headlining Gig at the Tempe Improv you
ideas.
It's pretty fun that that club is magic
club.
Yeah.
They redid it a little bit.
In what way does on the sides.
It's moved out into the audience.
So they lose like some of the side
seats.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
basically looks the same.
The green room is downstairs now with
the old manager's office.
Was,
was the old green room,
the green room.
They cut it in half and that's now a
manager's office,
so there's extra seats up there.
Um,
and a full bar up there.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Full working bar.
So you can like get up from your seat at
the bar.
Yeah.
Or the wages go up there.
I don't know if it's in player.
Not Interesting.
We didn't open the top.
Yeah,
that's cool that they did that man.
Joel's a bad motherfucker.
The guy who owns the Improv guy owns
West Palm.
The guy who runs all those guys.
Yeah,
they do it.
Fucking fantastic job.
So cool.
Having clubs like that.
It was cool because it used to be a
great club run by a maniac.
He got fired.
The old manager.
I mean they'll will own or got fired and
we're like,
what?
What do you mean?
How does the owner get fired?
They just doesn't sound right.
Like I wouldn't know.
Owner can't be around him anymore.
You crazy.
He was crazy.
He'd accuse people of like,
you still,
you still.
Champagne is like,
do we saw you walk out with champagne
last night?
I don't remember that.
Well,
we all do.
I can't say that on the podcast because
I don't know if it's true and he will
sue the fuck out looking for anything.
Yeah.
Don't say his name.
Whatever.
He's like,
candy man.
Hey Dude.
Gets fired from a situation like that.
They're probably not the healthiest
mentally.
The only reason I knew his name was
because he was a problem.
Well,
he was just any other manager,
owner.
It's like you don't even know who they
are.
They just do their job.
The only reason I knew who he was in
anybody's still talks about him,
it's because he was a problem without
saying his name again.
One time,
one time we showed up at the Improv and
we showed up like as the show started,
like I like to get there,
you know,
I mean I don't need to warm up and it's
some big deal.
There's a video that plays,
like if the show starts at eight and
we're there at 7:55,
who gives a shit,
we're not going to miss the show.
Don't worry.
Plus the has always liked to stay at the
condo right across the street instead of
the,
the Nice hotel.
But he was always there.
So yeah,
he was there already anyway.
Um,
so Ari and I got there and homeboy
starts freaking out and says it already
can't go on stage because he wasn't
there early enough because we had to
delay the cry on the phone as soon as I
went in there,
like the phone call for you.
I'm like,
interesting.
oh,
hey man,
what's happening?
Yeah,
you can't let the widget,
the latest show for 20 minutes for you.
Like what are you talking about?
It's eight.
Oh,
three right now.
And this show is going on.
Yeah,
she fucking.
What are you talking about?
It's so crazy because people had to wait
outside in the rain too.
I was just in the rain smoking weed with
broken.
We knew it was fine there no rain out
there.
What are you talking about?
He goes,
well,
you're not going on.
Oh,
I'm going on.
If there's one thing you're not going to
tell me.
It's I'm not going off stage that night.
No fucking way.
Well,
he's also,
you know,
when,
when you're in that sort of situation,
like it's not like he's your employer.
He like,
it's like a private contractor now you
told me that earlier in Boston when I
was like,
oh,
I shouldn't get high.
I'm going to go on stage.
And you're like,
who do you work at?
Is Four hundred 20 seat room on your own
for your comic.
So you're working for me and I don't
mind.
So go for it,
like,
well I just,
my attitude was um,
whether it's you or anybody or Duncan or
you know,
any of the guys I took on the road with
me.
It's like I already know.
You're funny.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't matter if you go up and
eat shit.
I know we don't have to impress you.
Yeah.
You don't have to impress me.
He can't get fired.
Right.
Like all you have to do is just keep
being you and we're golden.
So if you go up to high,
it'd be hilarious for all of us.
I was too.
I couldn't remember it.
My bits,
as long as you're willing to explain
that to the audience,
it becomes unique experience.
I didn't know that.
Then I told them I couldn't think of a
bit and I was like,
and I go,
hey joe Rogan's coming up soon.
And they all went crazy and I'm like,
why would I have said that?
That's being too high.
I'm not sure what to do.
Yeah.
But it makes it fun for me in the back.
It's fun for us out of it.
Well,
it's also,
you pulled
it out.
It's still a great show.
It was just really obvious that you were
high.
I'll tell you what though,
that second set,
that night I was going to real good
buzz.
Yeah,
and that was a fun set because I can
remember my bits and also be free enough
to refer around.
Yeah,
I think that's the way to do it.
I think it's like he get real high and
then you wait a long time and then you
go on stage until told us over the hump,
but you're coming down when you can
handle it like an hour and a half in
when it's all smooth sailing.
You don't want.
Matt Edgar was doing for awhile.
What?
First hit of the day.
They'd be like when?
When the guy got the light before him,
let me see.
It's three minutes.
He'd go to the back and he'd be like,
all right,
let's start smoking.
And was just smoke a shit low until
like,
all right,
that's it.
That's my time button because I run out
and go right on.
It would hit him when he was on.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
it's a bold move.
I think it's also a,
probably the most creative time,
like when you just wake up,
if you,
if you wake and bake and people think
that waken baking is really like kantar
counterproductive and you know,
waste your day,
you're not going to get never really
done what I have done it like in bed.
No,
no,
no.
I've done it like one of the first
things in the morning and I've done it
one on days where I have to do a lot of
heavy writing.
Oh really?
And I seem like it seems like everything
is really firing early in the morning
when you've had a couple of hits.
Seems like creativity is enhanced by the
rest.
Like creativity is.
I'm wondering in general to.
Well a lot of times man and people don't
think about it that way because you
think of morning is like when you have
to go to work,
right?
That's,
it's human nail is this,
you know what I'm talking about?
Human nail and I was just playing.
Come on.
How could that be possible?
Because someone else was in this box.
That's a human taste.
It.
Taste it.
It's on that box.
It's right on the box.
Hello?
Missing.
How could it be?
It's probably who.
Wait.
Who was here last?
Oh,
it's probably Duncan's Clinton.
Trump does nails.
If you imagine if you.
Do you want a podcast with someone who
watched them,
trim them.
How's you're doing as you're doing it,
be like,
what the fuck are you doing with those
gross thing?
It would be over somewhere in this area.
Scanning the rest of the table.
No,
I'm trying to find that one.
I'm hoping there's not a whole.
The US who smokes joints with random
strangers.
Who knows what kinds of fucking weird
fecal herpes you're passing around.
I put a toenail in my friends bond once
and he hit it and it smells friend.
You're an enemy posing as a friend.
You're a terrible person.
It Burns.
Smelled like hair.
So what was the experience like going to
this club and doing it with just you and
Diaz?
It was pretty cool,
but ds has a very strict no comp policy,
so it was all just on fans,
which nice.
But we didn't get like tons of like
those Asu chicks showing up wasn't as
much of the party.
No.
So he has a no comms policy because you
guys get a door deal.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
And also he feels like,
and I agree a little bit,
which just cheapens the ticket saying
you can get a ticket for free.
It makes it thing like you can get that
right.
And he goes,
I don't want to see that.
It's a good point.
I tell the clubs in New York and La,
I'm like,
listen,
I'll retweet stuff when I'm on,
but I won't if it's saying half price
tickets for free tickets to the Red
River,
I'm like,
I can't retweet those.
You don't want to like keep saying this
free shit of mine.
Well it's also the,
uh,
the audience,
their attitude about the show.
Oh yeah.
That's one thing that Joe is pretty
adamant about shows where people are
getting free tickets.
They're not going to treat it with
respect.
That was the downfall of Miami.
The Miami probably tickets was.
That was.
That was drunk.
Cubans were always there.
That Miami Improv was the worst major
players in the country.
It doesn't exist anymore.
It's gone.
Really gone.
I heard it's gone.
The the local comics.
It's like a little dance scene down
there in Miami now in south Florida.
They have a little harm and turning that
gig down.
I got hard.
Yeah.
Do.
I'm like,
nope.
Nope,
That's when I stopped doing like way
long ago.
More than 10 years ago.
I was just like,
there's no way I'm done.
This is a last.
I was saying it onstage.
This is the last time would come in
here.
Like there's no doubt this is the
dumbest club and wrong.
Everything is shitty part of town.
Well,
that's just the part of town was great.
The problem is they started,
they started giving away free tickets.
Remember there was all this cool
restaurants and outdoor cafes.
Oh yeah.
Right there.
Yeah.
That comedy club was.
They had the place where you get those
mixed drinks that the,
uh,
the,
the upfront.
Yep.
Yeah.
That wasn't bad.
No,
you go try to meet girls right across
the way.
When they were,
they all poured out and went to that
bar.
And then you were like a superstar.
Yeah,
I remember there.
Was that a cigar bar too?
They had like a cigar place.
You could sit down a little cigar lounge
and was ready to cry.
It was not,
it's not a bad little mall area.
The problem is that club had been
cultivated in like the worst possible
way.
Like the guy who was there before Joel,
there was all sorts of problems.
You'll manager try to quiet down at a
table.
I'm like,
dude,
this fucking 30 tables screaming at each
other.
What,
what them.
Why are you picking them out?
Well,
they would try to stop a flood when it
was already broken.
Yes.
Broken through.
You're putting their finger in to hold
back the dam with their hands.
I've never been there.
I,
I brought up a boxer's name in a bit.
I forget what boxer,
but they started arguing over you.
No,
fuck him.
You know,
Oscar de la Hoya,
enough Chavez,
and they were fighting in the audience
like who's the best boxer ever?
I'm like,
oh my God,
it'd be rude you guys,
but can you please be quiet?
Tables were yelling over at other
tables.
They were like monkey.
They were like,
they were crazy.
There were the wildest audience I've
ever seen.
I'd never seen an audience and I think,
you know,
you talked to them after the show,
like coming in because I was kind of
curious about how this is possible.
That one club could be so bad,
so bad behaved,
and it was a lot of repeat customers.
A lot of people,
so they just knew that's how you're
supposed to.
That's how it was there and that's just
what they did.
That's just how it was there and that's
what they did and so that's why they had
a tank.
The place they had cultivated and you
can't just let go the database because
you let go of the database.
You have all the email addresses and
everything.
All your customer.
You don't know what you're infected.
Exactly.
You don't know what the effective with
samples.
That place was rough.
I saw,
I saw dsp put people underwater there.
Wouldn't that be one of the southern
Florida ones were the ones that hired to
be a headliner killers.
That magnitude we needed to come down
here.
Dude.
I want,
I don't want to name names,
but Diaz did it to some people where
they like quit comedy for awhile.
I name names.
I can't,
I can't because he's a nice guy,
but he had to go on after Diaz and I was
like,
good God,
that,
that can't work.
That started.
I knew it wasn't going to work.
Ingram had somebody,
um,
that he was working with in Vegas and he
was kind of blowing them off the stage
and the guy said like,
hey,
you're doing really well.
I'm having trouble following.
And I was like,
okay.
He goes,
oh,
I'm just telling you right now.
There's no way we're going to switch.
I'll just keep struggling following you
because I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna.
Switch switch.
Why didn't Ingram was switching?
No,
he didn't even say anything.
He was just like,
it goes,
okay.
I respect that to firearm.
It was just like,
you know,
I can't follow you.
Wow.
That's so be it.
We'll Ingram's got a different style
because he works the crowd all the time.
Worked it.
Gets them riled up.
Yeah.
Working the crowd the way does a very
different kind of performance.
It's very,
very fun.
Very funny.
You just have to know a couple of
secrets that shit like certain people,
like you got to do a couple minutes,
crowd work to start two minutes,
then you can direct.
That's it.
Once you know that,
then you're fine.
Certain people,
it's just like there's certain ways to
follow them.
Yeah.
Um,
there's,
there's that,
but they also,
you know,
there's other people that can kind of
like set the pace and slow them down and
bring them into their world.
I've seen guys do that too.
Or the guy gets really riled and they
just don't get rattled.
They just start from a neutral position
and then work it back in and then,
you know,
20 minutes in or whatever they're
killing.
They're doing it their way to be able to
pull the mic away from their face more
so it's quieter so people can't hear
unless they quiet down themselves.
That's a good move to I guess.
But you got to have material to back
that up.
You know?
It's like when you were going on after a
guy who does crowd work,
are you going after a guy who does
music?
Anything that's like different than just
normal standup.
It sort of sets,
sets the tempo.
It's like going to see like captain
America want to see Captain America and
then you leave and it's an independent
black and white film about a couple of
dealing with the fact that you know,
childhood,
whatever,
you know.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean like how could you be in really
intense movie intense emotional movie,
but if it filed captain America,
I feel like what the fuck is this?
What is this?
I can be very
hard to get your minds to see captain
America has shitty wasn't it?
Wasn't shitty because I like those
movies.
Oh,
he's such a goody two shoes.
I don't understand this.
In the first one,
the guy,
the first bad guy who steals a serum,
he's got some kid with a gun to his head
and cut.
All right.
Take it easy.
Don't do anything.
Rash.
And the guy's like,
cool.
And then he just throws the.
He just throws the kid and then runs,
but he's still the kid in the water than
Captain America would have to save them
or kill that kid.
Take them with you.
Those are both excellent points.
Don't.
No other army said like,
well,
let's just get a kid.
Here's the best point.
All Captain America's battles against
evil.
Yeah.
Are silly because he's friends with the
hulk and he's evil.
The hulk is the bucket and ultimate bad
motherfucker know.
Why wouldn't you just call the whole cup
spider,
right?
But they're in the avengers together.
Okay,
so if they're in the avengers,
oh exists.
So he's having these fucking knocked
down.
Drag out,
fight to this guy and to go back and
forth and back and forth,
and somebody called the,
called the like,
yeah,
everything's done.
And he's jumping into the sky and
pulling.
Shout at sky.
That is a problem with the avengers.
Number one problem.
He's unbeatable.
So now you have this.
So the only thing you're waiting for it
to him to show that he's unbeatable.
Exactly.
It's waiting for the hug to just get mad
and start fucking everything up.
Like he doesn't even.
He doesn't.
He doesn't even put on an outfit.
Everybody else is wearing their outfit.
He's walking around with a fucking suit
and tie.
It's like,
look,
when the shit goes down,
I'm ready for you all.
You pussies.
I got your back.
I'm not even going to wear like a suit
and pretend I'm going to turn into the
hulk.
Like he's the fucking avengers knows
that he's out there,
that he's going to have to turn into the
hulk and he still doesn't even put on a
suit.
Yeah.
That's like if you have a friend who's a
contractor and you're building a fucking
extension or health or would you not
call it?
What kind of Yoga Pants is that
motherfucker wearing?
He.
They work on him when he is five foot 10
to 170 pounds and they also work on him
when he is seven feet,
five,
250,000
pounds or whatever the hell.
The hulk ways.
I mean,
how is it possible that the same pants
work on both dudes?
I would say that in the early years that
was more problematic,
but once it becomes part of the avengers
that they would have had the technology
to work,
why wouldn't they fucking get him an
outfit that he could change into and be
comfortable wearing this tiny man's
pants?
Like they don't make any sense.
You're wearing a dress.
Let's see the hog transformation.
Let's pull up the whole transformation.
Let's break down how ridiculous this is
because if you look at the difference in
size,
you're dealing with a person that's
like,
I would love to see a scale models next
to each other to see how those pants
could take.
How many times bigger as he.
Is it 10?
Like is he like 10 times bigger?
No.
He could fit in this room,
right?
No.
Couldn't even fit in this room no bigger
than a house.
Yeah.
He's way bigger than this room.
He'd be size of like a tank.
Do you ever see.
Do you ever see when he grabs the,
the,
the Loci Loci?
Yeah.
Dude Loki is like a six dude.
Like a
six foot tall,
six foot tall dude.
Oh,
this is the wrong one.
This is all of them.
Oh,
this is all of them.
those.
The original watch.
See the original one on television.
Which Lou Ferrigno saying that guy
would've been like size of more than a
house.
Right up to his knee.
The Lou Ferrigno is a giant guy.
Right?
But he was a human.
Like when you see in Lou Ferrigno here,
do all this stuff.
It's kind of hilarious.
It's awesome.
You know,
he's obviously huge.
He's a giant guy through that bag of
fucking coconuts at that there,
but there's a giant difference,
which.
Okay,
wait,
so now he's okay.
But he's the same size tank.
You should burst through tax breaks.
Yeah,
there'd be no room for the displacement
of water.
Right.
Would change radically overnight.
But look at the size of them.
Look how much bigger that is.
And his fucking pants still fit.
Oh yeah.
Now here's the Edward Norton did it?
Yeah.
You didn't know Ed Norton was the hug
was one of the better.
I liked him.
Apparently he didn't like it.
He didn't want to do it.
He's an actor,
but he's a really good actor.
I think he was worried about getting
lumped into this thing and becoming the
hulk,
you know,
but he was a good hall.
So Cgi afterwards.
Good acting there.
Aerosmith's daughter,
Erin start as a good actress.
She wasn't going to do this.
No one even there.
She should have said something already.
She's doing that.
This is the best though.
Mark refollow.
Yeah,
he's called.
I'm always angry.
I mean,
come on,
man,
this is a giant space shit,
but he's a size of like two cars.
No,
no.
You got to see him.
You got to see better.
Better images of him.
He's bigger than two cars.
He's gigantic.
It wasn't one of them where he got
bigger.
If you got angrier,
I would get double angry.
Yeah,
he would get bigger if we get more
angry.
You get even bigger.
Is there any metaphor with green with
envy with him or not?
It just happened to be green.
Just I think it was a gamma ray thing
because the whole idea was that he was
created in an accident with gamma rays.
Did you know that?
His name was Bruce Banner and the comic
books,
but they didn't want to have it on tv
because the gay connotations,
so when they changed the TV to David
David Banner.
Wow.
His name is Bruce Banner.
You're right.
Yeah,
I am right.
This is a fact.
What was in the avengers?
Oh,
I don't know a better be bruce banner
and the better assholes because they to
reduce TV show.
His name is God Damn Bruce.
There's nothing wrong with Bruce Lee.
Bruce become the gay name.
How could it be when Bruce Lee is one of
the baddest motherfuckers the world has
ever known?
How good bruce,
you know,
be in some way thought of as a non
favorite springsteen.
He sang it like Bruce.
Yeah.
It's the easiest that became the gay
name.
It's so weird.
Well,
how did that happen?
Oh,
it's very strange.
And why do one ear become the gate here?
Was that there sign a good question
because
I'm new thing.
Was that a real thing?
I had it in my left ear because I didn't
want to be thought of as a gay person.
Bruce Lee's going to be on the news.
Is going to be a character in the UFC.
Yeah.
It'd be able to unlock them.
Who sold that?
Right?
I don't know.
Probably Shan.
Uh,
his daughter.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
yeah man,
I had bruce banner was his real name.
Sharon.
Um,
I had a group of 10 people at the table
and Buffalo,
like table on fire.
Oh,
they had those candle things and I saw
the.
Yeah,
accidentally,
like they put like the just put a Napkin
over it and sort of like caught and I
saw them,
I'll look at it and then like through
some napkins,
but they're all just like panicking,
like they didn't know what to do when
there.
I just watched the Napkins all catch.
Oh my God,
why did they throw a drink on it?
Because they panicked,
like see them all just like their hands
were up.
You know what that is man.
Peoples' for girls' working every day
and not having to deal with real life,
real life,
but these were pretty 21 year old.
That's the problem.
They should be out there camping every
day fishing for their food,
fucking pulling roots out and then they
would see a crisis in act and they're
like,
oh cool.
It absolutely alive instead of this
fucking weird shadow existence.
We live in graduating college,
getting jobs.
You see that fight that was in Houston
at the chicken place.
Throw that up.
I love those fights.
Hip Hop real made.
It creates more of this.
Of course it does.
People Worldstar well,
the fights are going on that you always
kept buffering on roadster.
Like all the videos are always
constantly buffering fucking amount of
web traffic they must get.
It's got to be insane.
Where'd they still the computers from?
It shot up,
Brian.
It's probably a white people.
It's probably relatively
gold star.
I can save money.
This is a restaurant managers trying to
kick this woman out.
Can't see anything.
Houston.
First of all,
I was shocked the way the black.
This guy.
It's a guy or a girl.
Oh God.
You to guy grabbing her.
Tried to pull her away.
You can't do that.
Oh,
now it's a full brawl.
They're all going at it with.
We're pulling fat.
Look at it.
He's got that girl on site control on
the ground.
Yeah.
It's like judo baby.
All my fighting while holding a baby.
Oh my gosh.
She is fighting while holding her baby.
The baby wasn't even backing up.
She was going into this is saying,
you can't do this to get your baby out
of here.
And she's like,
don't touch me.
And look,
he's got her by the week.
She's got her by the we've.
No,
that's a guy.
That's a guy.
David Lloyd that employs a guy right
there.
Oh girl.
Got a better.
So they were all holding.
I don't think that's a weeds or hair
that's right here.
That's why it's so effective.
And when it gets a nappy weaves.
So what was this?
I didn't even get that order.
Well,
I heard two stories.
One inch.
One this a woman wanted a refund and
then that's what the restaurant is
saying is that the woman tried to take a
beer out off the property and you're not
allowed to take a beer outside.
You could only drink the beer inside the
place because it's illegal.
So that manager just went crazy.
They fired the manager up at this
restaurant.
I guess they're a supposedly like people
are picketing this restaurant and we
went to that whole topic too in Houston
and they always had that armed security
guard.
That's when you know,
you've getting some like yeah,
that's real Mexican food that the guy,
well it's just Houston.
Three in the morning gets kind of crazy.
Yeah.
That was a great restaurant though,
was still have the best Jalapeno poppers
I've ever had in my life.
They were legit Jalapeno poppers.
It was the whole Mexican food
experience.
There was legit.
They had Mariachi bands that were
playing
by the bar.
If I was still.
I got drunk.
I had to go to the bathroom real quick
and Barf.
Do you remember that Brian?
Yup.
You're like,
where did you just go?
Brian knew I was like,
what?
No big deal.
I did it fast though.
I thought I had it clear.
They had good Mariachi bands like you
would actually enjoy the really.
They were good.
They were talented.
So you'd be there eating and these guys
said,
uh,
and you know,
sometimes girls sometimes they never
check play too.
Wow.
Yeah,
they were really good man of food.
There was fucking bad ass too.
And after you have like,
like sometimes you know,
two shows Friday,
two shows Saturday let's go.
Fucking eat.
Slammed down some Mexican food,
2:00
in the morning,
hot after shows.
Massive peppers.
Yeah.
Full of.
Not even the cream cheese garbage.
Like,
Hey,
it's full of like cheese,
cheese,
cheddar cheese or something and it had
it had meat inside that.
What?
Brian,
when you were at San Jose and we were at
this restaurant and they're like,
Joe had to take this plate of food and
it had like a side of like,
I think it was a crawfish or something
like that,
bit the head off of it or I forget what
you did,
like you did the wrong end or something
like that.
We're just like,
oh no,
that's not.
I don't remember this at all.
I sort of remember that.
I think it was San Jose at Mccormack was
like,
that's not the end.
It's supposed to eat.
It was like a garden.
There was a little baby ones or
something and they weren't prepared the
same way.
You just got like a mouthful of brain
and I had a delicious.
Have you ever had that?
Like shrimp heads have done this?
Wasn't that?
I remember that.
Like I think you're supposed to eat it
like,
nope,
nope.
You're not sure.
In other countries it's probably a
delicacy.
Weird.
When you find out what,
what people
eat in other countries,
like,
um,
my friend Ed God was telling me that uh,
uh,
a store opened up down the street from
them and that they serve camel.
Really?
Yeah.
They sell it.
They sit a meat store and wasn't a
country America.
Fucking silver lake.
Oh,
I did that.
Yeah.
And uh,
they,
they serve camel sell.
They don't serve because they don't
cook.
It's a butcher shop and they sell camel
meat.
You're like,
I can't do this.
Can't be.
I can't prepare the camera.
Well,
this,
if they sell it,
there must be restaurants in La.
That service.
There must be,
it must be.
It's pretty common in the Arab world.
Camel,
camel,
camel.
I don't care for.
Dane had an episode of his show where he
was in Egypt and they slaughtered a
camel.
Like,
see if you can pull that up.
Anthony Bordain in Egypt with a camel.
You wouldn't need that.
You say,
Oh fuck that.
Why?
What's wrong with this shit is goat
head.
That's delicate.
Like a lot of people.
It's a real heavy eyes.
Eat the brain.
That stomach.
I've never had godhead head,
but I ate a deer head when we were in
Wisconsin and Montana.
We cook deer head cook,
especially mule deer.
They have a meal.
You killed them.
You'll know it's called a mule deer.
It's just the name of it.
It's dear.
Oh,
but when you,
um,
like,
like a,
like a monkey mind is also referred to
as a dolphin fish.
A lot of people think it's a dolphin.
Like you're killing dolphins.
No,
they call them dolphins.
It's actually a Mahi Mahi.
I'm not against Culligan Mule,
but it just seemed like something that
wouldn't be a hard one.
No,
I wouldn't be the hardest one to kill,
right?
Yeah.
I by a sheep kill Jay Hahn ranch on the
way to San Jose.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
man,
it's so big.
It's 2 million,
700,000
acres.
I mean you're like,
oh,
there's that ranch and then like 20
minutes.
And then you're like,
what?
We're still passing that ranch.
Yeah.
It's the biggest ranch in all of
California.
Wow.
This giant.
And we're going there and we're going to
shoot some pigs.
Yeah,
dude,
we're going to schedule that soon.
It's fucking fun.
I'm leaving.
I'm going back to New York soon.
Son.
Why would you do that?
Just because it's warm there in April.
He's a smart fella.
You're doing what a lot of old people do
in Florida.
I guess so.
Yeah.
I think that's such a great move.
Isn't it nice to have the financial
freedom to just travel around and do
whatever you want?
Yeah,
Bro.
It's the fucking nice civic.
Still got the bulletproof stuff that
soon.
That thing will never die.
Ever even had a problem with that car.
No.
Those things are.
God Damn.
I've never had their masterpieces.
I mean it's still got like manual
windows and stuff.
So what?
Manual transmission too,
right?
Yeah,
man,
I don't care about that but the thing is
it's got a CD player do it for a lot of
people.
Manual transmissions,
a deal breaker,
stuck in traffic,
having to use the clutch.
I,
nevermind that.
It's only hard when you're trying to
like repack a bowl or something.
Text.
When I drive,
if I drive like a and I know I'm going
to be on the four or five,
I never take the porsche just because
the manual transmission that's going to
stop.
Yeah.
And my manual transmission
is a tricky one to drive because it has
what's called a single mass flywheel,
which means the ribs.
It's like a race car.
The rose gold and they drop really quick
too,
so they rise up and then they fall
really quick too because of the fly
wheel.
So,
um,
that makes it harder for speed.
The ability to shift gears,
just it's a lighter flywheel but because
it's all about saving weight and cars
like that.
But when you're at a red light it's a
real problem because he wants to drop
off real quick.
So you have to be really much more
careful with it.
Yeah,
you'll stall out A.
Yeah.
Hills are bad too.
And you've got to fall back into people.
Yeah,
like that last one hill and it hits
sunset.
I've cooked many a clutch on that hill.
Oh God.
I'm always like,
take.
I'm like back back.
Stop it.
Well,
you worked the e-brake too,
right?
Yeah.
That's a real big fuck up that Porsche
did.
Portia,
did they have a button e-brake now?
Like you dummies that's needed.
That mistake that the manipulating the
brake with your hand was everything
that's on hills when you're parking is
supposed to pick that.
Put that on.
Now they just have a button electronic.
Right.
But the modular might be able to
modulate it,
you know,
being able to like pull a little bit and
then let go as you started.
I love doing that.
I had before that I had an old Toyota
and it was automatic and I will go up
the hill on sweetzer and when I'm at the
light I let go of the brake and put the
accelerator and it was just stand still.
We just couldn't go.
Wow.
It was just,
it didn't have the power and I feel like
jettison shit or just turn around.
My car has to fly wheels or something
like that.
So like if it's on a hill it just
automatically kicks in the other fly.
So then when you let go of the brake it
doesn't move.
And then you just hit the gas and just
go straight up.
That's interesting.
That doesn't make sense though because
it's an automatic.
You don't have an automatic.
So it's whatever it is you're talking
about.
It's probably a different mechanism.
Probably something to do with the
transmission.
It's probably a dual clutch transmission
clutch.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
The,
a lot of the modern automatic cars or
dual clutch now,
which that means is also that,
um,
the shift gears and insane amounts of
time real,
real fast.
Yeah.
Like,
like in the Porsche's,
like the gt three,
I think it does it in like less than 100
milliseconds.
What?
They didn't change it manually.
Yeah.
Oh,
way faster than they think that every
shift of gear,
like in a race is worth three quarters
of a car shift between a manual gearbox
and uh,
these double clutch boxes,
meaning that if they're both going along
the same speed in the same pace,
but one had to shift gears,
the one that didn't have to take any
time to shift the gears would get a
three quarter car length advantage.
Wow.
Yeah.
So yeah.
No over shift.
Oh,
oh,
per shift.
Well,
yeah,
because if you don't have to,
there's no the off.
None of that.
It's instantaneous.
It's fun driving a stick shift.
It is.
That's the problem.
The problem is like what
do you do in trying to race everywhere
on those hills?
Up in the mountains though when you were
like going uphill for like five miles,
you just lowered the fucking,
you know,
gear you're in pickup.
Yeah.
I don't mind it at all.
Especially the Porsche.
That thing is a ride.
Like you can't do that.
No,
it doesn't feel as good.
Like I have an automatic.
My bmws and automatic.
It's,
but it's a double clutch.
Automatic.
Like you can do it with a paddle shifts
if you want,
but most of the time I don't.
I just drive it.
The problem is that's an old style thing
that somehow sometimes more fun.
My aunt got this car and she got
automatics.
I'm like lexus or something,
but it had instead of a clock to being
digital,
it was analog.
It was like,
what are you doing?
It's just going to take the extra time.
That's a fancy car,
but you're going to get your eyes off
the road for longer.
I just trying to decipher that.
It's true.
Like this is a bad idea.
It's terrible idea.
Digital Id.
Digital clocks never became classy
though.
Never became closing.
No.
You know what I mean?
Think about all these like really super
expensive watches that everybody wears
number digital analog for awhile.
Digital.
It was just like it was a picture of
the.
The hands moving.
Oh,
those are crappy watches.
You don't remember that Brian.
I have this online to those new Samsung
watches and like the Iwatch type shit.
They have like the fake front where you
could just download new faces here.
Oh really?
So it looked like whatever you want to
actually kind of cool though because
it's cool.
It's almost like a little computer in
there.
I'm attempted to get that Samsung one,
which was the new one.
New One.
Phone monitors your heart rate watch.
They also have a small one where it's
just like a kind of looks like the fit
band,
like a thinner one that also does like
the heart rate and stuff like that.
Doesn't have a camera on then what you
call yourself after your workout.
Fitband,
you know they have a new galaxy s five.
It's out now that has a heart rate
monitor on it.
On the phone.
The phone.
What?
What did you just put it at a wrist?
No,
you touch it and hold onto it and it
monitors your heart rate.
Interesting.
So I could never use it.
I use it at the gym over in between
workouts.
Like say if you do like do some,
some fucking crazy kettlebell workout
and then you grabbed this thing when
your heart drops to a certain rate and
then you go again.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And it works with fit software.
They have software that's built in to
sure how drunk you are.
Yeah,
I had that.
I have that,
uh,
that galaxy note three.
I'm a huge fan of these things go really
well or it might be done with it.
I'm a huge fan of that.
Look how big that is.
That's fucking awesome.
14th.
June 14th.
What's that?
When they release date,
big iphones,
the big iphones sizes,
allegedly behind the fucking curb.
Those freaks since fucking what's his
name went down since jobs since jobs
into their fucked up,
left and right.
Mistakes.
Look how big that Goddamn picture of us.
Look at that picture.
That's sorry.
Before I shaved my head,
you look awesome.
But look,
I mean that's a huge.
It's very perfect crystal clear image.
It's just so
good.
I'm just,
uh,
I just can't believe that it took them
long enough to realize that that fits
easily in your back pocket and the
experience of going online.
The experience of looking at pictures,
the experience of taking pictures,
the experience of reading tweets and
then going to websites like someone
sends you a website,
it's infinitely better.
Like you could actually go to a website
and get a good web experience from one
of the brilliant things or it doesn't
even have to be that big.
Like the galaxy.
It's five point one inches.
This is like five point nine or
something like that.
The galaxy is five point one.
And
how much is this?
The new one?
I think they're all pretty.
Pretty similar points.
I'll buy that new iphone.
No,
the old one.
How much?
How big.
Oh,
it's tiny.
It's four inches.
I used to do fucking stuff on the old
envy.
Try to surf websites over that.
Difficult before they even had.
It was the one that popped up and you
had a little keyboard.
Isn't it crazy that that seems like a
100 million years ago.
There were no mobile sites still,
but you could get on their sites,
but how much
different have some inventions been in
that time?
Like how much?
Like cars are pretty much recognizable.
Exactly the same back then.
Almost exactly the same.
Yeah.
Not that much difference until I breaks
with a before.
Like they look a little slicker on the
outside.
Like the new Mercedes is like.
Yeah.
But other than that you recognize it.
If you could go back in time 10 years
and get into a car,
you'd be fine.
No,
I didn't even have a phone 10 years ago.
Hey,
cell phone?
No,
I was late anyway.
Really?
Yeah.
And we're in 2004.
He didn't have one.
Get out of here,
bitch.
You're crazy.
No one ever lived in that place.
I didn't have one for a while.
When did you get one?
What year?
Two thousand five.
Two thousand six when we go on the road
together,
but not always like God will eventually.
I found one.
I found a prepaid one in New York one
time when I was visiting and so I used
that for awhile.
I sat by it for about an hour waiting to
see if somebody comes back,
I'll claim it.
Otherwise you don't have to use a phone
for the whole week.
And I was like,
Oh,
this is actually nice.
It's better than a pager.
It's way better than a page or dude,
it was 2004 really old Nokia with snake
and that snake snake was good.
Dude.
I had a star Tac.
Remember those are tech.
What is that?
Remember those?
Was it a Mitsubishi who?
Motorola.
STARTAC still still use a flip phone.
Does he?
Of course he does.
He has an iphone too,
but he doesn't use that as much.
He enjoys being an old man.
Yeah.
I had one of these.
Let's see,
image that looks like or people who
worked.
Yeah.
I have one of those and it had an extra
battery,
like the battery,
like stuck,
stuck out on the top.
You'll see.
Look how easy the batteries were to get
off.
Oh yeah.
You were pissed about that when the
iphones came out and like,
come on man.
Give you the option.
Yeah,
stupid.
Well that's the other thing I like about
this phone.
The Samsung,
I have an extra battery that I keep with
me that it's fully charged and this
fucking thing.
We'll go for a day and a half and any
point in time I popped the off,
put the new
battery.
Boom.
It's fully charged.
Really?
What does that the note.
But guess the notes.
Three notes through.
Yeah.
And on top of that man,
I sound like I'm in a no commercial and
then having a note for.
Well,
they're going to work on right now.
Just know.
Yeah,
this,
this one's fairly recent,
but the,
um,
the other thing that's super cool is
this,
my ideas,
my joke ideas.
I actually write them like,
look at this.
Whoa.
It's all a notepad.
So all of my ideas,
I actually write down like I don't need
to carry a notebook anymore.
Like my notebook now.
Like my actual physical handwriting
hurted so bad.
What's that?
Her Tattoo is so bad.
Frosty asked me that and he goes,
what did you just write down?
I'm like,
no.
He goes,
what was it?
it's not a joke.
It's just almond shaped nipples to write
that down because I might get back to
it.
You never know.
Right.
I'm just.
That's so funny that you said that.
I'll tell you why later.
I won't remember.
I have a thing about almond milk over.
Like it's one of the,
one of the punchlines is that humans
don't have tits stupid.
You can't get milk out of an almond.
Like don't call it milk.
Like almond milk,
almond milk,
rice milk.
It's Whitewater Weird fucking cup water
doesn't come from a nipple.
You fuckhead.
But that's like a whole bit.
I did.
So when you said that almond shaped
nipples,
it's hilarious.
He surprised part of the Vegan bit and
surprise.
You don't rock an ipad like an,
like a small ipad.
This is a small ipad.
I mean essentially it is.
I don't need dude,
when I go on the road,
I oftentimes don't even touch my laptop.
I just fuck around with his phone the
whole weekend,
like answering emails and stuff,
doing that work stuff.
That's pretty cool.
It's the big one for me,
man,
is this,
the big one for me is the set lists that
I can write my set list down to instead
of a piece of paper.
I like having it in my pocket.
I do too,
but I like this too.
This is also,
it's like it doesn't replace it totally.
I still carry a notebook everywhere.
That would have been a lot better when I
was using those,
but the thing I like is as I flipped
through to find the note that I want,
I see the old notes.
I'm like eventually it will come out on
stage because I keep seeing it.
When I was writing notes in evernote or
something,
I wouldn't see the old notes once I made
a point to go back to them.
Well my notebook.
There's a difference between my notebook
and this is I would say more of like my
idea book,
like this is where I'll throw ideas in
what I want to write them down and I'll
throw like set lists,
but like my notebook is more like what I
do before I go onstage.
One of the big ones is I write down all
the different shit that I want to talk
about,
make sure that I like,
that's how I remember and that's how I,
it helps me like make sure that I don't
leave anything out to give me like all
these little points and then physically
writing down,
I sort of,
it sort of cemented in my head.
So if you go over and look through my
notebook,
you'll see like the same notes over and
over and over again.
I'm like,
are you fucking crazy?
Because I'm just feeling inside.
I'm just filling in the space.
It helps you remember?
Definitely,
yes.
And then occasionally I write new things
there but I put a big black star next to
new things that are right there.
So what I use a notebook for and what I
use like my computer for a totally
different,
like a very rarely write a bit on a
notebook because I can type so much
faster than I could write.
It seems stupid to me.
I,
if I have a great idea for a bit I'll
read.
I'll jot down what the idea is real
quick.
But then I do all the writing on an
actual laptop.
Oh,
right,
right.
I'm have to write longhand.
I don't think you could fuck with the
camera though on the iphone.
Unfortunately.
That's the only thing that keeps me from
going 100 percent from was better than
better.
Quicker.
Apparently the galaxy five though is a
little bad.
Oxy Five.
That's the Google one,
right?
Yeah.
Apparently the camera's pretty dope.
Have you guys ever broken your iphone?
Yes.
You have.
You have dropped.
It just dropped the regular drop into
the shadows.
Yeah.
It smashed him.
Believe it or almost me neither.
I've dropped it a billion times.
My,
my iphone just does things like what
it's doing now.
Like things start,
stop working.
Like my speaker doesn't work.
Yeah.
That's what happens.
It goes off when you have 25 percent
battery life left,
but just like,
no,
we're going off on.
You plug it back in and you still have
25 percent once you started up again.
She was a new thing that happens when
you just can't trust it.
Really have an alarm because my,
after I updated the last firm,
I stopped doing that stupid shit.
Oh really?
Like,
or were you just sitting there on your
phone?
Just suddenly has been as the CIA,
the NSA,
digging in your Dick Pics.
I talked to one mother fucker.
I'm just going to reboot them.
I'm tired of looking at a giant shoe
Dick.
Just see what they're doing now where
they're just like the like,
all right,
we're gonna make the.
We're not going to spawn here.
We're going to have the phone companies
store for like,
you know,
up to a few years.
I'm like,
that's still have access to all our.
Still ridiculous.
It's just more.
They said this ahead of time,
like,
look what Obama's going to.
He's not going to reel it in.
He's just going to rename it
and people are,
there's,
there's good points on both sides and
one thing that people go over all the
time,
they always say like,
hey,
if you're not a criminal then it's not
gonna affect.
You don't waste any time thinking about
it.
That's not true.
And this is why it's not true.
This is the big one.
It's not true because like let's say
that you were running for office and
let's say,
you know,
they could,
you maybe you'd be a great mayor,
maybe you know,
maybe have really good causes in,
but maybe your fucking secretly gay.
Oh yeah,
sure.
You know,
and maybe they could find that shit out
before you come out and give it to a
reporter.
Absolutely.
Or maybe your cards.
I would definitely do that.
Yeah.
Maybe you to go to get hand jobs and
they find out about your fucking horn.
Love it.
You're fucking going to.
You point to number one through 100
bookmark.
So you've got nothing to hide,
but you're like,
no,
I have things to hide.
The private things to hide and say stuff
like if you've got nothing to hide it.
Like what if I have two lighters?
Yeah.
And I want to still have my two
lighters.
Like now I can't like come on man,
all this shit.
You don't have to have anything to hide.
Yeah.
Just leave me alone.
This is not like,
this is not an issue where it should be.
People should have access to what you
look,
what you enjoy,
what are your issues?
It gets to that like red scare thing of
the 19 fifties,
the McCarthy era.
I mean that's really what people,
what they have to stop criminals that
stop terrorists.
It's like,
okay,
but we have a set of rules in place
already.
Do you have to do it that way?
That's why we make cops like,
well that stuff criminals.
Yes.
But if you want to start somebodies
house,
you need a warrant.
Yeah.
I don't know how it feels to stop
criminals.
I don't know how effective they are
stopping crime by.
They will never.
They just keep pointing to that.
They have,
they have,
uh,
a memos that they all sent out to each
other saying,
use nine slash 11 to justify this.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
It's pretty horrible.
It said,
well,
you know what?
I'm still doing it.
We're like,
oh,
no control.
Let them do whatever they want.
I'm thinking of becoming a narrow list
thing of saying fuck it.
Just a nihilist.
Like,
I don't care.
Fine,
do whatever you want.
Let me just be clear.
I'm libertarian now.
I think what you should do,
which is just continue being honest
about what you think about everything.
But at some point like,
don't you ever feel like I'm going to do
anything?
I don't think it does do something.
I just think it takes a long ass time.
And I think one of the big things that
it does is when people.
And this is going to sound kind of
silly,
but it is true when people make jokes
about things that joke changes a little
bit of the public's perception and
what's,
what's your givens are based in,
in the job will like save guy like Stan
hope regard like you does a bit shitting
on the Tsa and you do a bit that makes a
lot of sense and it shits on the TSA is
that bit becomes popular,
that bit gets out there into,
makes people feel a little bit worse
universe.
But then what happens?
Well then what happens is public
perception changes and what the public
perception changes.
It starts to shift who people voted on
based on what they support and what they
don't support.
So if you go over a certain threshold
where like all these people want this
and eventually the boat for them.
But like legalize marijuana,
there's no,
there's no candidate where you can
actually get that even though most
people want it.
It's moving that direction.
And it really is.
I mean it's obviously moving in that
direction cause something like that
though.
You'd probably need like 75 percent or
something where the old people are
outnumbered.
Well,
you really need is money and that's what
what they have now and money changes
perceptions mean the reason.
One of the reasons why advertising,
CNN things you're seeing on weed,
the Sanjay Gupta pieces.
It's not just that it's true,
it's not.
That was because there's a public shift
in perception and that public shift in
perception accepts things that it would
have thought of as drugs during the
Nancy Reagan administration.
You know,
Nancy Reagan was doing that just ain't
no shit.
You could have never had sonjay gooped
on CNN and realize they can get Sanjay
Gupta talking about like how we should
be good and we're like,
oh,
we can actually get viewers.
If you put that on.
We got a lot of people who want to say
it's definitely that,
but there's also like what's going on in
Colorado is the amount of money that's
being generated by weed is undeniable
now and they get so much and there's so
much going on that it gets to a certain
point in time where people are like,
hey,
there's no crime spree starts
influencing all the politicians.
The money starts influencing all these
different people in our corner for once
it comes to marijuana lobby essentially.
Yeah.
We were just.
But that's the problem with that.
That should be.
That should even be allowed to have to
work what?
Okay.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
It's nice that we're working in our
favor this time.
It's not necessarily working in our
favor either.
It's just beginning to work in our
favor,
but.
So you think after a number of people
hear about something and start to
influence their opinion?
Yes.
Then the government will then to appease
those people will change their mind.
Well,
it did.
Change is who the government is just
takes time.
It changes what the culture is,
what the culture accepts with the
culture doesn't accept,
but it changes and it changes based on.
A lot of it is public perception.
A lot of it can be influenced by art and
music.
Things that get out there that get
people to resonate and his ideas and
then money.
Money is the other big one.
So when the thing is it has all of them.
There's all these things and money.
Yeah.
So when a big business come in and say,
okay,
well maybe 50 percent of people are
against something and it will be on our
best interest to like if you,
if they're not against it,
if they're for it.
So they just come in and say if there's
maybe 50 percent of people against it
for the percent of people for it,
they want to shift that and the
politician's mind the importance of
definitely.
And that you support that CNN and things
like,
you know,
have a television show that shows the
positive side of weed.
That will definitely shift thing.
Or like the unions in New York,
they're trying to keep mma out.
Whether like just get through to the
look,
look at this guys,
brain damage,
barbaric.
Nicholas Chicago politicians go,
ha,
that's a stat.
I've seen that stat.
So yeah,
there's,
there's most certainly that.
What you're seeing with like what's
going on in Colorado too is that people
are getting old enough to that.
The people that are like in their
twenties and thirties that are voting,
they've grown up with the internet and
they know it's bullshit.
You're not going to own them the way you
own 50 year old people today.
You're not going to.
Someone's saying this.
That's why Arizona always vote so
conservative.
It's the old people moving there and
it's not the main regular people in
Phoenix and tempe and stuff.
They're cool,
but it's like old people and they vote
and way higher numbers and they are
afraid of stuff.
Do you think that the older you get,
the more conservative you get?
Yes,
because it can't just be because they
were like,
well,
you know when the old people die on.
I'm like,
they have already to just from when I
was five,
they have already died out to an old
quote.
I forget who was quoted was because show
me,
I'm a young man who's a conservative and
I'll show you a man with no heart.
Show me an old man who's a liberal and
I'll show you a man with no brain.
Huh?
Funny.
I forget who made that quote.
I forget where it's coming from me,
but the idea is as you get older,
you realize a lot of what's going on is
people need to just stop being fucking
babies.
They need to get their shit together and
need to.
You know,
you need to have stricter laws to cut
back on the nonsense and recidivism and
crime and you get tougher on crime.
As you get older,
you get,
you know,
you want your streets to be protected.
You're like,
God dammit.
Enough is enough.
I'm 65 years old.
You're going to go out.
So like,
who cares,
kill 'em,
all Kev,
all these goddamn criminals.
You start getting that of an attitude.
You also start going like,
I like things done the way they've been
done and so you just don't want change.
So I think a lot of times with gay
marriage,
things like that,
it's the same kind of like a push back
that you'll get when,
uh,
when the Catholic church turned the
priest around,
[inaudible] father told me that,
like they,
everybody went crazy,
turn the priests around,
one point he was facing the audience and
then the big,
the Catholic thing that they all deal
with the big meeting they've had to
have,
you know.
Yeah,
a Vatican two,
whatever it was.
Then they say,
okay,
now you face the arc or whatever the
front with the people or vice versa.
Okay.
Turn him around.
And he goes,
remember our parents losing their minds,
no way to worship.
Well you kidding me,
and now I want you to take it for
granted because that's the way it's been
done.
There's no way to worship.
And people go crazy because they want it
done their way.
And when you've used this something for
50 years of your life and suddenly it
changed.
Wait,
two guys are getting married.
No,
this is not the way I like it.
This is against the sanctimony to
sanctity of a marriage.
It's the same shit that when your,
when your favorite restaurant takes an
item off the menu,
like what not.
That was the.
I like that item.
I want it done my way.
Hmm.
I don't know if a restaurant taking item
off the menu because of the same place
for them.
They want it done their way.
They've been going to that restaurant
for 45 years.
What do you mean yelling at a club
sandwich anymore.
That's my.
That was my thing.
People don't resist change and I think a
lot of that is insecurity.
That's a lot of it.
I think a lot of it is a that did just
scared.
People are scared of marriage is one
that does not affect the people not
involved in it.
Brian,
pull up the story.
The Dea,
a cops raid woman's home after she shops
at an indoor garden center
because they're there.
They're watching what?
She's right where she was because the
dea thinks she's growing marijuana.
I saw that in the trash.
They took the trash out.
They didn't test the shit.
Yeah.
So how do they even know about it?
I mean,
it's crazy.
Nothing to hide.
Well yeah,
but meanwhile they busted into my house
and did a bunch of damage.
She came under investigation just
because she shopped a store,
you know,
Indoor Garden Center.
So they thought maybe she was building a
bond with that without fertilizer or
something.
I
thought she was growing weed.
That's what they thought.
But the idea is that this woman didn't
get caught for any other crimes,
so they have a warrant.
They went through her garbage and they
stormed her home and an early morning
raid after spotting her shopping at an
indoor garden center that they had been
staking out.
Like,
come on man.
There's a real problem with our lives
when you're going after people.
Yeah.
Two books on how to grow marijuana.
They found some,
some weed stuff in her house.
So they were.
So what zip drive from 1982.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
But so what the point is,
first of all,
get people will abuse power.
Guess what?
There's no,
there's nothing wrong with fucking
marijuana.
Okay.
Can we just establish that?
Can we stop at the ball and like five of
the dea.
Why would the dea thinks that it's okay
to stake out a fucking garden center and
then break into people's houses?
So what did they find when they broke
into her house?
They found
shared like nine grams of marijuana.
Oh No.
Really?
Her own stuff.
Yeah.
So they said they found nine point three
grams of marijuana in her art room.
Jesus Christ.
So she smokes weed and does art.
And what happened?
They broke her fucking house,
door down,
rated it with guns.
Here's my friend told me about it.
Once in a minute,
it's pretty clear.
He goes,
I get a government not wanting you to do
certain things.
I don't agree with it,
but I get it.
Don't smoke marijuana,
but if you are,
if you are smoking pot or doing whatever
you're doing in your own home for them,
just tell you you need to surrender your
freedom.
Now the one thing you're granted as a
citizen of this country is your freedom
and say you have to give that up now for
up to a year or two.
We're taking their freedom from you and
you can never vote again because we
caught you.
That thing.
That's a whole nother pr.
That's a whole nother whole nother thing
and here's the other part of it.
They.
They investigated a month long
investigation that involved federal
agents searching through her garbage and
comparing her electric bill to those
have a couple neighbors.
They searched through her garbage and
checked her electric bill and that the
fact that she was spending money on
electricity for whatever fucking reason,
a bunch of other stuff.
I'm sure she was,
but who cares if she was growing wheat?
The idea that the on the,
on the presumption like,
oh look what you're doing.
Where it's like,
no,
she just had some in her house.
Well,
the only reason they arrested her.
The only reason why they did it,
the only reason why the investigator it
was she was shopping at a garden store.
I mean,
that is fucking crazy.
You can't just do that.
How long until the government fucks with
you until you say fucking slap their
hand away.
Well,
this is one want to fund that.
Another one is recent because this one
is people that actually were dea agents
that we're breaking down the door and
they were looking for um,
you know,
on,
on civilians.
He pay attention on the fuck you doing.
Looking around for something that I want
more.
I'm still listening.
Will have to roll a joint.
What did I say?
What we're talking about?
Civilians busting the door down.
The thing where you just,
you just,
you don't,
you haven't listened,
but you pretend you still place a couple
of words.
The point is they did it recently to
these two former CIA agents growing
tomatoes and the fucking,
the feds.
The dea broke down their fucking door
and came in guns drawn.
These were former CIA agents because
they were growing tomatoes actually in
their garbage.
They said it's weird and they didn't
test it.
They actually had vegetables like there,
there were doing it totally legit.
Just trying to grow vegetables in their
basement and the cops use that as an
excuse to break down your door and point
guns at you.
If that doesn't show how bananas
everything's gotten,
if they think it's okay to actually
point guns at people because they're
growing something that's fucking crazy,
that's just fucking crazy.
The fact that these cops think that it's
okay to do that.
Whoever it is is giving them the
direction,
whatever fucking help guide or happy cop
like they have in Albuquerque,
they should dogs on them almost
immediately when you shoot them,
even small dogs and they do it to scare
the fuck out of people.
I mean they also do it to let them know
like,
this is real shit.
I just shot your dog.
I will shoot you.
Then they'll.
They did do it to intimidate people and
they do it because a lot of them are
just fucking sadistic.
Says Crazy Shit,
man,
man.
Crazy shit.
That is unacceptable in a civilized
society.
It's unacceptable.
The idea that this is a good thing.
The idea that you're protecting anybody
from anything like that in any way,
shape or form.
This guy saying,
you have to knock life better.
Record cops.
All those like,
that's not true.
Then you can record.
Kafka doesn't let them do their job.
It's just keeps them accountable.
Yeah,
you're supposed to.
You're supposed to be able to record,
but there are some states where you're
not allowed.
Right.
I think there are a few states that are
fighting it,
but that shit's ridiculous.
Like you're recording news,
like it's actually happening and when
cops are being recorded,
like they.
Did you see that thing that I tweeted
about la having cops were these things
about Korean?
Everything they do.
Oh really?
And when they do it,
they found a drastic decrease in
complaints.
A drastic decrease in.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
beyond the record.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I forgot the actual statistics,
but they're are pretty fucking shot.
They want to record all of us,
but they don't want us to record the
cops at all of them.
Exactly.
It's hilarious.
It's congress still exempt from
obamacare.
Do they exempt themselves?
I don't know,
but somebody had a really fucking good
point the other day.
What was ever said.
They said,
how is it not insane that you're talking
about a country that doesn't force
people to have proof of their
citizenship but does to have proof of
your health insurance?
Do you know how crazy that is?
They're crazy,
so crazy.
They're saying you don't have to give
proof of being a citizen of this
country,
so you can be an illegal alien.
No one.
Everybody will leave you alone,
but you do have to have proof of the
fact that you're paying an insurance
company money so shitty.
It's when we sell this people picketing
in Tempe.
The last time I think we all went there
and I was like near the mall and I was
like,
what if picketing for it was the first
time I was like,
they must be a reason why these 100
people are out,
and then I realized later it's like,
because I just thought it was like,
yeah,
I got to make sure everyone gets health
care,
but now it's like another.
You're forcing everyone to buy insurance
so the insurance company can still make
a lot of early.
The way it's been explained to me,
it's not obamacare as much as it's the
affordable care act,
which is tacked onto obamacare.
There's,
you know,
whenever you have bills that are,
that have good intentions,
all sorts of special interest attached
there needs to bills and things that get
passed off and have these clauses that
have no nothing to do with it.
Yeah.
Not only have nothing to do,
but they have like far ranging
implications on the simpsons when they
were trying to get out of town,
like the built a vacuum at the simpsons
because the media was gonna hit them.
It's like all in favor.
It's like I'd like to tack on a pro
pornography bill with that.
They all voted against it and I'm like,
ah,
and that is what they do and can back
and was like,
this is why democracy doesn't work.
Yeah.
So they tack on Shit.
So with the affordable care act is
different than obamacare.
Allegedly.
I haven't investigated enough.
Peter Schiff will probably know his
time.
He has a podcast probably educate me on
it,
saying they fucking gets crazy and start
screaming about it.
Insurance companies aren't like good,
it's not like good at what they do and
then you're like,
well,
too bad you have to have that bad deal
about the idea of insurance.
It's fucking crazy.
The idea that you're going to gamble
whether or not you get sick or hurting
coggins fucked up and if it does,
these people pay for it,
like the whole economy sort of pay for
it.
They'll enemy of credit and the whole
economy of like being able to purchase
things in advance that you can pay off.
All of that is like a kind of financial
indentured servitude and almost everyone
falls into it.
When you want to talk about college,
College on the grid begin before you
have any show and they got you in debt
already and they get used to it for free
tee shirt that's has fucking umass on it
or what's going on with college
sweatshirt was his name.
Belushi Lucia.
Yeah,
one of those on white.
I don't even a cool one.
Yeah,
you.
If you really stop and think about it,
that is exactly what happens,
right?
You go to college and they know these
kids don't have any income,
but they're still giving credit cards.
They know they don't have income.
They will only default and they're
chocking up all this debt before.
I mean,
think about the idea that you have to
pay for four years of,
of living.
That's a bad deal to after it's over.
Yeah.
Like four years of everything for a year
you have to pay for four years of back.
Pay It back.
Like if you had to do four years of
anything and then pay it after it's
over.
What a mess that would you imagine if
like you,
you like all your food went on credit.
I just finished my,
my student loans just paid it this year.
Last year.
You paid them off scare a long time ago.
Oh Wow.
That's so scary and doesn't want me to
but like 85 bucks a month more than.
I think that's probably why.
Yeah.
For this deal.
It's like,
well,
it's not even a good deal.
Well,
it's the only way to get a career
though.
I guess you have to pay for college and
everyone going up to jack it up.
Some scholarship scholarships are pretty
sweet.
Private schools cost a shitload now to
fuck you and I do feel like 15,
20 grand at least more.
Even when I was going to was five or
seven.
Some of them are 30,
30,000
to educate a fucking seven year old.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Oh Wow.
Just for smaller classes.
Yeah.
Well,
for more individualized attention for
goods teaching for good students look
bad.
I mean we were all smarter resource
resource loss in this country.
A lot of it goes from kids being
disinterested in education.
That's a great resource.
Laws,
people,
people doing a shitty job of raising
their kids and then kids getting shitty
teachers.
Yeah.
They have this out as like,
well parents got to do a better job.
It's like okay,
but they're not.
So then what?
It's not just that.
It's also dealing with other parents
work.
Like when you send your kid to school,
you're not just dealing with your
parenting and what you've done for your
child.
You're also giving other kids that are a
mass and you can see shitty parents and
you could see all this different shit
that happens with kids that are just
real fucking nightmares.
Real crazy.
Kids disrupt classes like it's not just
your kid,
it's everybody doing a shitty job of
raising kids.
It's not just you making sure that you
do a good job.
Kids going to have to deal with dummies
friends too.
It's nurture just beyond you.
There's a lot of shit going on.
What's on TV too?
Let's to play apart.
Well,
that's where community really comes into
place and that's what I kind of
understand.
Gossiping way more now.
You know?
I understand.
Oh,
explain that.
That's interesting.
I understand gossiping way more now
because the more things get fucked up in
your community,
the more like in situations like raising
children and so they're all kind of
aware of what the soldier.
I heard so and so's son is dealing.
You'll also hear like,
oh,
this guy likes to scream at his family.
You hear him yelling at his wife and
you're yelling and you're like,
that's.
I was like,
oh,
we got a problem in our community like
this public shaming,
public awareness.
Well,
this gossip does.
It's also like you're trying to set some
sort of a standard,
you know,
you're trying to,
uh,
trying to make everybody get along
together and when you've got one person
that's a fuckhead or this guy is,
he's constantly drinking,
he's a drunk.
You want to be aware and the community
of where the weak links are.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
I mean,
that's what it,
it's not just people mind their
business,
it's sort of they have to mine other
people's businesses because you've got
to find out where the problems are,
you know,
especially when you have children,
you want to wear.
Look if you've got one kid that skin and
cats and doing free.
That was a good to know about that kid.
What I had really tight knit dorms.
It was always,
that was the biggest problem with
gossip,
but it was also coming from a place of
like everyone's door was open.
Everybody knew each other,
you know,
it was a nice thing.
Yeah.
I think there's good gossip and you
know,
there's,
there's just get ahead.
When I left,
religion was like sense of community.
Right.
That makes sense.
And then no one was gossiping about me,
but I've lost that.
Like team.
Yeah.
That sense of community is important for
us.
It's important for human beings,
you know?
I mean essentially that's what we're
putting together,
but you know,
having this group,
but we all gossip about each other.
Yeah.
But we do it at least lovingly.
You know,
like we actually want everybody to have
a good time.
Like we want everything to be in order,
but if we find that someone's being
retarded about some shit,
bring it up.
Yeah.
He liked to.
You see what that silly bitch to do
that,
but because we're interested in them.
Exactly.
It's and it's,
it's also about some God never met.
I'm bored by it.
Yeah.
It's like,
all right,
guy cheated on his wife,
Brian Start Smoking again because it's
cat hurt her foot.
I mean we have to talk shit about that
because it's so ridiculous.
What happened is this silly bitch
fucking cat her.
It's foot.
You and that the best reasons to start
smoking,
you're like,
all right,
look,
I got to tell these guys saw,
which I tell them,
you know,
I'm really into an accident.
What I'm disturbed about this cigarette
band,
this electronic cigarette band,
because I have looked into it and I,
I think it's ridiculous.
Well,
I think the third hand smoke,
that's what they're saying.
Now.
What's thirdhand smoke?
I think this is ridiculous.
What's third hand smoke?
If I smoke in this room,
this room now can give you cancer for
the rest of its life in the future.
That doesn't again.
Is that real?
Yeah.
The reason I heard about this thing that
they're saying now is that there's this
thing called third hand placement that's
smoked in like houses and stuff.
No Way.
That's insane.
I thought they'd banned because people
were like,
this is gross.
Everyone's smoking those things and it's
annoying.
It's just one of those salon.com.
Is this real?
You know,
it's awesome.
I tweeted something today of this seven
beers that you should stop drinking
immediately.
Like castle has like this chemical or
this coloring in it.
That's been proven to give you cancer.
Newcastle,
hold on.
And
this third hand,
smoke is generally considered to be
residual nicotine and other chemicals
left on a variety of indoor surfaces by
tobacco smoke.
The residue is thought to react with
common indoor pollutants to create a
toxic mix.
This toxic mix of thirdhand smoke
contains cancer causing substances
posing a potential health hazard to
nonsmokers who are exposed to it,
especially children.
So like if somebody wife's tables out
down,
if it had cigarette smoke,
like honor from smoking around a lot,
it was my wife that down,
it would combine with that is possible
with that.
That's exactly what they're saying.
And what they're saying is that other,
um,
indoor chemicals can create a toxic,
a toxic mix.
So it's not that smoking in a room can
get you sick.
Is it smoking in the room and somebody
coming in with windex,
but they're going to do that.
Yeah.
It's the chemicals interacting.
So,
but what I want to know,
what I'm saying is if they didn't do
that,
if nobody ever cleaned it with any
chemicals,
there was no chemicals exposed to it.
Then it will just be a room that
somebody smoked,
but it makes sense that the walls,
that brown color that you see at pool
halls where you know,
dudes been smoking there for 50 years.
That shit is like on the wall,
the walls he has like when you see other
than the ceiling above blitz with
candles.
Oh yeah,
just color.
Yeah,
but that is at least just you could
stand on just fire smoke over the years.
It must be so deep.
Those places like those old school
places where it's almost like the walls
were yellow from small or old people's
houses just like smells in there from,
from the years it's talking about.
I couldn't even.
Might not even be now,
but to it in the nineties when I started
playing pool,
everybody in these pool hall smoked and
the air conditioning was horrible.
Really?
Ventilation was horrible and I'm so.
So you'd go to a pool hall and you would
walk in the door and you would just
immediately be greeted by a cloud of
smoke and you just dealt with it.
That was just what you did.
You go over to the table and dudes were
smoking and putting their cigarette down
on the table,
whether a plan it was,
there was cigarette burns,
those lead there have those gold crown
tables and they have that sort of farm
for Micah look like fake wood railings
and there would be burns all over the
railings,
believe in people cigarettes.
So it was super common.
But you student poker rooms where you're
allowed and not allowed where you had to
go out to the rail.
Wow.
So you just run out there and smoke and
this is so fucking annoying.
I was looking at my yearbook and I was
like 1989.
It showed all the things that happened
in 1989.
And it says like 1989 first,
uh,
any flights over or under three hours.
Ban On cigarettes,
on the airplanes was 1989 only three
hours.
Yeah,
I can remember.
It was longer than that.
I can remember it.
I can remember the band.
I can remember when it happened.
They had a curtain smoke section to
them,
not smoke session.
It was hilarious.
That's hilarious.
Imagine if you're there with your baby
and some guy behind you is chain smoking
and you're just like one row ahead.
You have a baby with you that is so
fucked up.
Yeah.
They had the ashtrays in the.
In the Bay Watch was on TV.
That's how stupid people were done was a
country Thomas couldn't check out this
article,
eight beers that you should stop
drinking immediately because it has all
these chemicals in what article?
Number one is new and put it up on the
screen.
Number one is new castle,
kind of a caramel color in class three
and class four Karma color.
That's made with ammonia,
God,
and it has cancer causing qualities in
it.
Oh,
why would they have a fete color to
their beer?
So make it seem beer.
I will not buy you now because you're a
fake bitch.
Budweiser.
Let's see what that has.
Gmo Modified Gmo corn in it and gmo rice
is anheuser busch.
I'm not sure.
It's not as bad as cancer.
Here's the thing,
man.
I'm not sure if it's even bad for you at
all.
There's there's two sides of the fence
on that.
GMO,
they won't allow you to research it.
Right?
Wait a minute.
Is that true?
Yeah.
They just tried to ban everything.
They can't be sued for anything they do
wrong.
All those people,
they just try to get the shit out there.
Well,
we'll certainly there.
There's people that are profiting that
are trying to curb the regulations as
much as possible to maximize their
profits.
For sure.
That's happening.
My question is,
is there anything that shows that GMO
corn is bad for you?
Because there's apparently has nothing
for you in general has no nutrients.
It's got carbohydrates.
Carbohydrate mean there's something
corn,
but yeah,
your body doesn't digest it very well.
That's why he's always hitting your
shit.
Yeah.
That's why you see coronary poop because
your body's like,
what is this man?
Exactly.
Wow.
Well,
if you've ever seen that king corn
documentary.
No,
but that's a good man.
I let that.
We'll put it on out there.
What?
Play some Florida.
It's pretty dope.
Um,
and it shows you how deep the corn
industry has its grip.
That Gore America food.
Yeah.
Like high fructose corn syrup.
Kevin Smith told us about it.
Man,
remember he was,
when he did the podcast,
he was the one who told me to check it
out,
but they.
It's in everything man.
High Fructose Corn Syrup.
Yeah,
that's replacing sugar.
Replace sugar in so many different
things.
Just doesn't seem as bad.
Government subsidies,
dude,
there's government subsidies to give.
The government gives corn farmers money
and incentives to grow more corn.
They grow corn for cattle feed and then
the cattle feed makes cows fatter,
so you're dealing with these corn fed
cows and they're like really fat and
sloppy and delicious and sometimes they
get like ulcers in their stomachs
because their stomachs are not designed
to process corn.
Oh really?
Really fat and like when you see a steak
at the market like you were seeing as a
sick cow,
look at all the mumbling,
Darlene,
this is going to make a delicious steak
on the grill.
With that is is a fucking sick animal
really?
Because you're giving them nutrients.
Well,
you're giving too much fat,
giving them too much sugar.
You're giving them too much.
Starts scribbling.
You're giving a grain,
you're giving them something.
Their body doesn't want,
their body wants grass with a cow's
body.
Naturally ease is just grass.
They graze and they just mountains out
there like towards like San Jose.
We just see them like Jesus.
Go ahead and go,
you know,
like somewhere nearby,
somewhere shade.
Sometimes they grain finish cow where
they'll feed them on grass.
Then before they butcher them,
they fatten them up with grain.
So his whole life.
He grazes and then um,
or she grazes.
So he mostly he steers.
You don't eat meat.
Yeah,
you do.
You do steers because I was just going
to say kind of sticks with those same
shit.
Yes.
Takes most of the time they're coming
from mail cows.
They're coming from steers.
The female cows are very valuable for
their dairy.
So the male cows,
they cut their balls off and they turn
them into steers.
Can't really eat them.
Bull,
you can eat a bowl,
but good fucking luck will never become
a real man.
The steers are all Unix.
Yeah.
Well that's the only way you can control
them.
You can't cook like,
first of all,
good luck thinking that you're going to
be able to run a profitable business of
butchering bowls because they're not
gonna want to let anybody corral them in
anywhere and control them and they're
gonna.
They're gonna like you're gonna have to
take extra measures to keep them happy.
You can't go out into the yard filled
with bowls,
you know,
instead of it taking extra measures,
we've cut their dick off.
If I have to cut their balls off,
a lot of this stuff is still probably
can't be in there with them.
You know,
they're giant.
Have to have a deck,
right?
You'd have to pee.
Got To pee,
pee.
It keeps giving them vagina.
No cross dressing.
They eat the balls to.
That's where rocks come from.
No people.
Cowboys.
Those are watching.
That's what rocky mountain oysters are.
After they cut off the cows balls,
they,
they cook them up.
It dawned on him.
Yes.
I had both balls on Israel.
It's not bad,
but a mixed grill.
Yeah,
it's nice and soft.
Yeah.
I had it once at a m,
one,
a chef cooked like fear factor food and
that would be delicious.
He prepared it well and so he did it
like with a with balls and did it with a
couple of different things.
I want to say that was on opiod Anthony.
Really?
That they prepared it like that.
I'm pretty sure it was on opie and
Anthony.
I can't remember now.
They all become a blur.
Those fear factor interviews,
but a bull's balls tastes like just meet
like I kind of.
Meat doesn't taste bad at all,
just like liver.
Almost to me.
Consistency.
Once you chop into it,
the consistency.
Yeah.
It's a little more mushy than let
literally like a tenderloin or something
like that,
but chicken hearts are really good too.
Chicken hearts,
they had some of the trials.
They have chicken hearts.
Yeah.
It's someplaces tastes delicious.
Delicious.
It's just really.
They're small.
If you've never eaten it,
Fogo de Chao of you don't know what
we're talking about.
What they are is a Brazilian type of
steakhouse called the [inaudible] Korea,
and I just realized that most people
don't know this because I had explained
this.
I never knew what it was.
You have a.
it's the Brazilian way of cooking steak.
It's fucking an awesome way to eat.
You have a card in the card,
has a green on one side and a red on the
other.
Some places it's a fixed salt shaker.
Made out of wood.
Yeah,
turn it upside down with green and red
and when it's green they keep coming to
your table and they sliced meat for you
and you pull it off with tongs and
different cuts of meat like,
hey,
here's some top sirloin.
Would you like it?
Yes or no?
Skewers.
These big giant skewers of just awesome
looking meat and it's all covered with
like,
you know,
they like salted and the basting in in
its own fat because it's spinning in
this,
spinning on a Rotisserie,
over an open flame and they come by your
table and just slice off chunks of me
and God damn.
It's awesome.
And would they give you lamb?
Small lamb chops,
chicken hearts,
we've probably eaten in.
How many of these?
Almost all of them.
They just opened up a window in San
Diego to write down.
Well,
they used to have a one down there that
wasn't a Fogo,
but it was another Brazilian that was
not a fogo with somewhere in Maryland
and it was just like,
what the fuck bro?
It's so good.
Just more and more delicious chunks of
meat to it.
Not only that,
you get the party started in like five
minutes right away.
You don't have to order your food and
weight up to your waiter.
Yeah.
It just keeps coming and the sidebars
and not bad is awesome.
So it was great.
We doing commercials here,
fucking Samsung commercial to get this
out to the sides.
Otherwise it meets stage with some beans
and some,
some Broccoli.
We send in some fiber to open up the
poop shoot early.
Warm up for the poop poop comes behind
it.
Have you ever shot at a photo or Jessica
Maria and then gone back to eating a
probably.
Who have done that?
Brian created room for yourself.
Last time I went there,
I actually decided that I was going to
take it slow instead of going really
fast and just eating as much as I spent
like two,
two hours.
They're just really just hanging out,
getting to coffee and then going back to
getting me.
Oh,
like I just.
You're a nightmare customer.
Wow.
Was it a sold out night?
No,
it was just like an afternoon Sunday.
That's cool.
Yeah.
I mean if you're one of those people
that really wants to take advantage of
it,
I'm a glutton.
I'm done in 10 minutes,
10 minutes,
then I could probably quit.
There was one across the street from the
hotel and Cincinnati.
Yeah.
Vandelay checking in as we were going
over there and like midway through,
like we had just started the meat.
He just jumped in,
like he put his bags down and went.
I was Brazilians.
Yeah.
They learn how to eat.
I also want to stick with the Kanye and
they.
I know that they're really special.
Pecan Kanya means yes,
obviously.
Yes.
Give it to me.
You're stingy with it though?
I think.
I think think that costs the most money.
Lamb chops is what they're stingy with.
Where the fuck have the lamb chops all
the time?
No,
they're not stingy with anything.
Guys relaxed.
How come it takes a long time to cook
this shit?
A lot of people are eating.
They're not stingy.
It's all this dingy.
It's more than once you.
So Julian it up right now.
The guy that put the little hot dogs
feel so bad.
He was always running around anybody.
Anybody taking a Goddamn hot it because
they cook their own meals.
So he feels like he must be.
He's depressed one of the bunch.
He probably just gets no pussy.
He probably goes home.
It could ask.
Diaz wants it like,
well done.
So will you go?
All right.
I'll make a piece well done for you
because every time they cut it off,
now I want to talk more real on the
inside.
They'll,
they'll cook that part.
Go back.
Yeah.
So good.
It's such an awesome way of cooking
food.
They really have got it down to fake
after the show.
Oh,
the street.
Yeah.
That's pretty good too.
Sure,
let's do that.
That place is fine.
I've got no problem with that place.
Yeah,
that's a great way of ordering meat.
There's a Brazilian steakhouse in the
mall.
That's fantastic that you just asked
them and they just pile it all up on
your.
Oh yeah,
you're good.
It's not quite the same way.
The joy of just like whatever I can eat.
It's definitely not quite,
but it's still pretty fucking sporty.
Yeah,
I like it.
they just have that,
that mall.
But you took me to Brian and the Grove
has went to Glendale,
so when you see a big fat piece of
marbling on a steak,
it's cooked perfectly.
It's so delicious,
but it's really not a healthy animal.
Oh wait to take us back,
like how did we get here?
That's where we started after the dots.
I like it.
I had a fucking farmer on last week and
talked with them for three hours.
Real farmers,
real farmer.
This Guy Joel Salatin,
he's famous for doing what he calls.
He calls it,
um,
integrity,
meat and in integrity farms,
like the way he runs things,
they,
the animals live essentially like total
free range boobs.
The chickens around.
He has electric fences for the cows and
the pigs moves them to different areas
of the farm unless they just completely
roam free and rummage through the woods.
Like he's got.
Pigs are wild pigs,
but they're there.
They're domestic pigs rather.
But they behave some wild look like wild
pigs and a lot of ways,
like they're really fat,
but the muscles like really defined.
They have a darker tissue.
They're much animals.
Even about salmon.
Right?
The pink coloring they get,
they get that in the wild.
In captivity.
They just add that shit.
Yeah.
The,
that coloring because we've agreed that
salmon should look like,
isn't that weird?
When you lose the coloring,
man,
that's something to do with your soul.
Nah.
Something,
right?
Yeah.
You did the coloring of it.
Does it have the same nutrients?
I wonder what it is if it's certain bugs
that they eat or you know,
certain shellfish or what it.
Let's find out what helps.
What makes a a Sam?
It seems weird that everybody just cool
with that.
What would be the right Google thing?
What makes us sam and less pink?
Hot Pink when say they die.
They die.
The Salmon.
Yeah,
but in the wild they don't die in the
wild is just pink.
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah,
because I think it's like Disney when it
dies,
how old the fishes?
It gets wider,
like at least.
I think it probably loose now as it gets
older.
No,
no,
no.
It still stays correct.
Yeah.
What happens is there's something that
happens.
Okay.
The amount of height.
Oh,
it's something about the protein pellets
that they feed them.
Takes away their color.
Yeah.
Wow.
They put the pellets instead of eating
other fish.
They would it be other fish?
They would be eating other fish.
They'd be eating all sorts of things.
Man Fishing was so cool.
Yeah.
They're like,
these are like couch potatoes is what?
How they're describing it,
but they just sit there and eat bon bons
and you're like,
yeah,
healthy.
Yeah.
That they're essentially they're
consuming.
This is what it says here in Swat
article.
They're consuming a tremendous amount of
high,
highly concentrated protein pellets and
uh,
they make it terrific mess.
Oh God.
Apparently like,
like these fish farms are like super bad
for the environment over.
Really?
Yeah.
Why?
Because they raised a lot of the same
issues that uh,
other places have.
If you have chickens or cows like fecal
matter shit.
So you're,
you know,
you have like a gigantic pool of the
fish just shitting on each other.
Yeah.
Shitting and pissing each other's faces.
Oh,
I'm the drain it buried somewhere and
then they're like,
floating pig farms says this one guy
who's a professor,
fisheries at the University of British
Columbia,
they consume a tremendous amount of
these things,
these pellets.
And then they just piss and shit in
there.
That's it.
You don't even think about that.
But disease and parasites,
which would normally exist in relatively
low levels in fish,
scattered around the oceans can run
rampant and densely packed.
Fish farms is all there.
The bugs shit and everything happens.
I don't even know if that happens.
I get that show.
Nine hundred 70 pound tuna fish found is
almost $2,000,000.
Oh,
that's chicken of the sea.
Those things that's worth $2,000,000.
That's what they're saying.
Going to Tunis store.
Yeah.
Probably the five chefs in Japan.
Right?
Oh my God.
That thing is so big.
Pull of that picture.
Again,
that is just holding a fish,
but that was just the fin.
I would love to see the perspective.
I'd love to see a better angle that
doesn't in any pictures.
Doesn't come forward.
It's not flattened out like that.
It's hard to.
I mean it looks obviously like a house,
but God not at seven pounds.
That's insane.
That is fucking insane,
man.
In New Zealand going to China.
You go to China,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
Just to fuck around a tour.
That's pretty cool.
It is pretty cool.
Yeah.
Is there a common.
I mean,
can they have.
They have Australians and English people
and other English speakers that are just
there.
So they just put on bar shows.
You going with Schubert?
No,
she was gone that tour though.
But uh,
no.
It's just a run.
Okay.
Here's what it,
what it is.
Salmon.
I've found out the actual answer,
the actual cover of salmon flesh varies
from an almost white to a deep pink,
depending on the levels of carotenoid
asked,
asked to Aksia thin what has a t,
a x a n,
t,
h I n whatever the fuck that is due to
how Jennifer Aniston instance as ass tax
a tax anthon due to a rich diet of Krill
and shrimp.
So depending on how rich their diet is
of true of shrimp,
they'll get darker,
but we associated with being being
healthy or color of the thing they're
eating.
Exactly.
And Salmon raised on fish farms are
given artificial coloring in their food.
Like if you.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's even more fucked.
So it gets into their meat that's even
more fucked up.
The pellets of artificial in pink dies
their skin brown yesterday.
Well apparently people want us pink.
So now we're even pink.
How weird.
Your eating pink food.
Like green eggs and ham.
Yeah,
but pink does that a real thing?
If you eat carrots all day long,
you'll turn orange.
Yes.
Andy Dick turned orange.
You did it?
Yeah.
How long have you do it for?
Didn't eat carrots all day.
He,
uh,
Andy,
believe it or not is kind of like a
supplement nut.
They always had like a,
like a box.
Boys are not a supplement of.
He always had a box of vitamins that he
would,
uh,
take everyday and he would drink like
these fruit drinks,
juice drinks,
and he would drink carrot juice,
carrot juicing.
So much that he actually got like an
orange hue to them.
Wow.
Yeah.
Andy Dick being orange.
Yeah,
it was,
it was a very odd.
It's a Mitzi to call a sinbad's orange
is orange.
Look at um,
he's not black.
He's rng.
Oh my God.
You know,
that's.
I totally shocked with that.
You can get a little bit of a coach.
You remember that dude who,
uh,
eight was that,
that silver stuff.
Silver.
He drank some silver solution and turn
blue permanently blue.
Really?
Yeah.
He never seen that.
If I know you've seen violet beauregard
pull,
pull it up.
Man's skin turns blue.
Was it blue?
Like silver
blue port.
Fuck wow.
Yeah,
he was a like colloidal silver.
COLLOIDAL silver.
It's like one of those things where you
like you,
you like a lot of people got into this
thing with colloidal silver and curing
colds and like,
yeah,
this is the guy.
Whoa.
Yup.
That's just what it looks like.
Yeah.
This is real skin color forever.
Forever get mail.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it stuck that way and I don't think
they ever figured out how to get it off.
I'm either and so he just makes his
living going on talk shows and showing
off his freak skin.
How dare you do industry.
This is just him educating the world are
a why you have to be so cynical.
He's got a profit.
How's he profits on a set somewhere
while looking at him,
I said maybe this is what his house is
decorated like you're really into modern
shit and Mike's on his lapel.
I would dye my hair pink or something
like bright red hair.
The.
Oh yeah.
The pink and Blue Combo.
Can Blue lanyards for a checksum camp?
Put Pink and blue.
A landlord.
I think people would probably,
for the oddity of it all,
I'm sure,
but he's probably already married to
now.
The girls like we're going to stick it
out,
but I'm less attractive than it was
before court guy.
I wouldn't mind it.
I don't think that's bad.
You wouldn't mind that.
That was a girl started taking colloidal
silver sun.
If it was a chick that had purposed,
I think it would be bad as I'd make her
have pink hair be sweet.
You would like to check that looks like
she's made out of metal.
It should be unique.
It would be unique,
you know,
like look like I'll be dating an alien.
I just make sure that she had the right
color hair and she did the record with
like,
you know.
Cool.
How would you make sure that she would
do that?
I would style her out.
What if she was like,
I want to go green today at the hair.
Go now listen to me,
bitch.
You are me.
You are nuts.
You're imparting to me when I'm out.
You represent.
Represent me.
Oh,
some bitch with glue skin,
green hair.
Your pink hair.
Where the fucking alien close just
wearing a fucking alien clothes.
Okay.
We bought them for a reason where the
alien close.
I see it.
Check with this.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
That's kind of girl.
Looks like that.
So excited.
He found a girl.
By the way,
my next storyteller shows on Tuesday,
April eighth.
Get the fuck out of here.
How's that possible?
We're not recording it.
It's just a live one.
Who's doing it?
Diaz.
Matt Bronner.
Good.
Emily Heller.
Rob Delaney.
Good God.
Good God,
that sounds awesome.
Tuesday,
Tuesday.
The all stories about role models.
Oh Wow.
What is that?
That's when a girl that had this.
She just looked like bad lighting.
Yeah.
She looks normal.
Mother Pearl kind of issue.
It is.
I can't tell what the light.
What does it say?
What does this story say about her?
Uh,
see a woman has turned silver.
Warren's it's hard to tell him that.
Hard to tell because it will be dim
lighting.
So it was a tough color to pick up our
internet medicines.
Oh Great.
Joe,
you recommended me to get sober.
Colloidal is the same shit.
Yeah.
After she took nose drops for years
warning people to stay medicines
containing the metal from nosedive
and this from colloidal silver.
Yeah,
same shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
and the FDA approves it.
They still like,
okay with that.
I don't know about that.
Do they have a half to approve colloidal
silver?
I don't think they have to approve it.
If it's an APP,
it's a nose drops.
What is that silver that that.
That one week Dr gave us that one time
that was like you looked at it looks
silver and he's like,
Oh yeah,
just spray it in your mouth.
Was that the shit?
No,
no.
I know what you're talking about will
have.
It wasn't that way would that is in this
guys.
God is totally the colloidal silver.
You'll actually make it like he put the
silver pieces.
You put it in like water and you add
some sort of electric current used to do
it.
My friend Demetrius take chloral silver.
Yeah.
They used to believe in him.
If he got sick.
My friend Pete,
a smoked a gold blunt wrappers are
selling gold blunts.
Actual gold.
Gold is the weirdest thing ever.
A lot of people don't realize,
so it was a very smooth.
You can take a piece of gold,
like a little tiny piece of goal and you
can cover something as big as this whole
desk with it,
which because it could be so malleable
to so thin,
it gets so thin.
It has really bizarre properties.
Almost alien like properties because
there's no other metal that exhibits the
same as the old alien spaceships.
The goldmines I'm told or it was where
the old alien spaceships ones of the
earth and just created this.
I don't think so.
I think it's just an unusual mineral.
Okay.
I mean we know it's a similar to a lot
of other ones.
It just has an incredible property,
like the ability to spread and coat
things.
Good conductor to.
Cool.
Well that's her blue check.
No,
that's,
that's fake.
But I do like to pink and blue hair
though.
I see what you're saying though.
Brian.
We lived in.
The lights were off.
If that wouldn't be a problem at all.
Getting tattoos though and getting those
big hoop earrings and fucking their
faces up anyway.
Why don't they just drink the silver and
blue skin?
That'd be pretty cool to be a unique.
Different.
Definitely easier than getting your
whole body tattooed,
so it was for a little while.
If you get it for a year or something,
you know people.
What's.
The tattoos are forever and these girls
are getting face tattoos.
I say Walmart on it
just forever.
No one's getting face tattoos and say
Walmart and Walmart.
These people say no one really looked it
up.
Oh,
I would love that woman who at a
gambling casino tattooed on her
forehead.
Just gambling casino or the name of this
Golden Palace.com.
Remember that she had it tattooed on her
forehead.
They gave her a certain amount of money.
Yeah,
I think it was one of those things where
anybody who's willing to get it tattooed
on their head get like extra money.
Wow.
They used to put it on fighters.
Backs member.
There's tattooed on.
Yeah,
the Henna.
They used to use to use like a magic
marker and it would draw it on people's
backs.
Do you remember know whether you'd use
body paint or something like that?
On the fighters,
they did it with MMA fighters,
like uh,
one
of the guys a Rico Rodriguez.
He did it to him before he fought in the
UFC and he got in trouble for it because
it was looking at this Walmart,
Walmart.
Wow.
So they're going to go for it could
joke.
I like it as Walmart tattooed on his
kind of like ears.
Ari Is that real though?
Really?
It's pretty good.
Photos off is not the way the girl is a
probably a hipster.
Yeah.
What'd you,
when you say stretch marks on her side,
but still in shape.
I don't know how you got to have those
go off.
Fall off.
Fall off the wagon.
That's what it is.
Do you worry about letting your kids
watch certain things on TV?
Like what?
I don't know.
I mean I,
you want them to watch too much
violence,
but they've walked in during the UFC
fight before and sat down to cuddle with
me and that real confused as to what's
going on.
Like one guy was getting fucked up and
there was blood pouring down his head
and I had to decide like how to react to
this when she's watching this,
they're trying to be like.
And she's like,
why is there all this cut?
Why is all this blood?
I go,
oh honey,
he got hit.
He got hit.
Why did he get hit?
I go,
well,
this is a fight.
And sometimes when you're fighting you
get hit.
Is he hurt?
Yes,
he's done,
but he's going to be okay.
He's going to be okay.
Yeah,
he's going to be okay.
But why did he get hurt?
He got hurt because he's doing mma.
What's MMA and amaze the UFC was the
UFC.
UFC is mixed martial arts and you know
like,
hey listen,
we can't have these conversations
because I want to watch going on and
it's already an exciting morning.
It's important shit.
But it was a,
you know,
was awesome.
Mommy,
go talk to mommy on it,
baby.
What happened was I was watching it and
they weren't home and so when they came
home they ran into the room,
why?
Why not?
And I didn't shut it off and it was
already in the middle of a fight,
so it was one of those things where I
was like,
yeah,
you guys probably shouldn't be watching
this.
But they didn't freak out.
Go ahead,
get your ppe on dancing.
They didn't freak out.
That's cool.
They didn't.
They've never freaked out when they saw
hunting shows either.
And it hasn't taken anything away from
them.
I don't think.
I don't,
I don't want to expose them to any,
uh,
any real violence though,
you know,
even even mma is probably too much for a
five year old kid to say walk in and see
a guy getting ground and pounded.
It's just something like,
I don't want that.
Do you want them to get into mma when
they grow older?
Would you like them to get into Jujitsu
and all that stuff?
I think that people should do what they
want to do.
And I think if that's something that
becomes something that they think is
exciting,
if they think that a nma looks like it
will be fun or Jujitsu looks like it'd
be fun.
And then,
yeah,
they should do it,
but they don't.
And they think that something else looks
fun.
They should do that too.
I mean,
I,
I teach them things.
I've already started teaching them.
I think it must be hard for a girl to do
something like Jujitsu because I know
talking to a couple girls I know,
didn't you just so that they're like,
yeah,
you run into the guys to have the boners
they're,
you think they're,
they're just
like trying to grind their dicks on you
and stuff like that.
There's was going to be done.
It's way harder for a chick to finish
for a guy.
It's way harder for them,
girl to find good training partners.
Too much less,
um,
less women do it.
So a woman who like grinds it out and
becomes purple belt,
Brown belt,
black belt,
like those women are bad ass man.
That takes,
you've got to be a special type of chick
to gut it out and become like a Jujitsu
brown belt,
Jujitsu,
black belt,
you know,
to become like a real world class.
Like Rhonda Rousey type Black Belt,
you know,
she's a judo black belt,
but you know,
same sort of thing to get to that level,
man,
you got to be something really special.
You really do.
You've got to have something that just
pushes you past everybody else.
Like when you see women and women that
fight in the UFC and they have a jujitsu
black belts,
like God damn woman that has a Jujitsu.
Black belt is a rare thing.
It was a bunch of them now,
but still much more rare than male black
belts.
Male black belts are everywhere.
I mean,
I don't know what the numbers are,
but I'd have to say it's gotta be like
10 to one or something like that.
I mean,
I don't know,
I'm just,
I might be totally incorrect,
but I would,
I would expect it would be somewhere
around that.
I don't think he does know.
Um,
but there's a,
there's some legit ones out there,
man.
I'll tell you that.
That's for fucking sure.
How many of them are lesbians?
I don't know.
Why don't you ask them Dude,
whip your dick out.
That's what it was like a crazy thing.
It's like a girl saw guys,
Dick,
like literally nature had made it so
that all you have to do is show someone
your deck.
Like as soon as we started covering it
up,
nature made it so that if you have a guy
pulls his dick out,
like there could be like a room full of
women.
They all dropped their needs.
Just start talking at like nature just
confused the shit out of you and so it
becomes illegal to whip your dick out
because it's like it's breaking the
rule.
It's like they would have no choice.
I can't imagine how crazy society just
catch people sucking people off for no
reason.
Like what are you doing?
He pulled it out.
Asshole.
Don't pull.
You're to start with.
You pull it out.
I wanted to give them a textbook.
I know,
but there's a reason we have laws that
would be the last people who lock people
out for Pomona,
Dick out in front of other people lives
plain about it.
Why we stopped.
That's our natural.
It sounds ridiculous,
but sodas,
like almost all the weird shit like
having to go to sleep.
That sounds ridiculous,
that every night you have to close your
eyes and the thing stops and it goes
into some crazy land where your eyes are
moving around back and forth inside your
head and you're fucking pastoral flying.
That's just way weirder than you pull
your dick out and people just start
socking it.
Right?
It's a real thing.
You're downloading some shit.
Well,
you're tripping.
That's what you're doing.
You're tripping your balls off.
I balls back forth.
They're pretty
sure that what's going on in.
It's hard to measure it,
but they're pretty sure what's going on
is dimethyltryptamine that there's a
release some form when you wake up and
goes out real quick.
It just like,
okay,
I'm fine.
They know now that a rat's produce it in
their brains while they're alive.
The pineal gland of the rat's brain
producers this dimethyltryptamine and
they're pretty sure that it produces it
in high doses during periods of stress
or during,
um,
during rem sleep.
Extreme stress where you think body
thinks it's going to die in Rem sleep or
two times where it just floods you with
it and they don't know how to measure it
in the dream state.
Like how to get reps,
trying to work on figuring out how to
measure that.
Because to measure it,
it's,
it's really difficult to run these kinds
of studies because it's a schedule one
drug,
but it's also something that your body
produces.
It's real weird.
So you're,
you're,
you're monitoring schedule one drugs and
their appearance in the body.
What testosterone in your body,
but they ready to register.
Regulate that too,
right?
That's true.
But texts testosterone,
illegal.
Yeah.
It's not illegal.
You can get it prescribed what the issue
is with a dimethyltryptamine is that so
prevalent on I got to do it at some
point you do.
It's so goddamn prevalent.
You've never done it,
Brent or you have not done it and you
don't think I should do it.
Why not?
Don't listen to him ever
personal.
Uh,
he didn't like the Salvia thing.
I love the Salvia thing.
I keep saying,
I love that.
It just looked weird,
so mad at me.
Well,
you were fucking with him while he was
tripping.
Watched it.
What were you doing?
You were just being totally silent.
No.
Was.
I was hosting a podcast and then trying
to get some stuff out of it and,
and I didn't know he was that fucked up.
I was just like having fun.
But then once I noticed it he was really
fucked up.
Then I tried to make him not stand up.
You're already the devil so you fucking
with him until you realize he was fucked
up.
We stopped fucking.
Yeah,
exactly.
We were doing a podcast was when you
come out of that thing,
it looks like you're better on your
back.
Like when see,
I think see hung did it or somebody did
it first once I'm Asian guy and it was
like.
And then he came and he's back.
He's like,
oh well how was that?
And he's still like square and not
totally back at all.
You're just not like gone.
Salvia is a tricky one man.
It's tricky that it escaped all the
regulations.
So you need a spotter to do dmt.
He should have.
It should have one.
You should have said what?
Because as you like the pipe,
I know a lot of people who have done it
without a spotter.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
This is the lender.
The lender will go off once you.
You're in this world.
What if he's like,
stand up and it knocked something over
and you're gonna be on the ground in la
La.
Land as a candle.
NARCS over and you don't have candles.
Do it on the floor.
Ready?
Write you a check.
No,
the ones with the candles.
Candle.
Listen,
if I go over dude's house and he knows
I'm coming over and he likes a bunch of
candles,
I get my fucking my guard
up.
That makes it smell better.
It also makes it gay or I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that,
but when everyone's clear on each
other's intention.
I love lighting.
Trying to give me a massage.
Look really tense.
Hey,
what's going on with the candles
scented?
I make them crushed my own roses.
I make my own candles.
I lovingly put them together and I would
like you to have to keep it by your bed.
Yeah.
There's something about candles,
so don't have the candles.
If you're gonna,
do DMT by yourself.
You don't want to let your house.
I'm just have a spotter for sure.
If you can have a spotter house.
Barbara spotters getting away.
Sometimes it's like,
well,
I need to do this and then you got to
have some for them to.
Well,
not only that,
sometimes they like interrupt.
I'd want to be alone and just have my
experience completely.
Eddie Bravo starts snoring.
He fucked up my trip.
I was on.
He was right beside him.
He was snoring.
I heard him snoring and I had to wake up
in the middle of the trip.
Go Eddie,
wake up.
You're fucking snoring.
He was spotting or he was doing.
He's supposed to be.
He just took a nap.
It was like you were gone for so long.
I'm like,
what?
Said it's a 10 minute trip.
It is.
He took a nap,
take a nap.
He couldn't wait.
If you have any existing schizophrenia
or anything like that,
you might break your head open.
You might just.
That is the thing you struggle with an
ordinary reality you might not even know
about.
Yeah.
You might not even.
Well,
there's a lot of people that are in
denial about their own mental illness,
but there are a lot of people that don't
know about it yet.
That's the only weird thing with those
things.
The people who would like suddenly it's
like boom,
you're turned wolf.
Yeah.
I wonder if that would have happened
anyway because people just become
schizophrenia.
You know?
It's possible.
I don't know what the chain of events
that have to take place in order for
someone to go loony,
but I know that it's happened with and
without drugs and I don't know
necessarily the drug's fault.
There's with some folks.
It could be though.
Some folks have had a pretty hair
raising stories of not coming back
entirely and folks that they knew that
it didn't come back entirely.
How setting off a schizophrenia episode.
Yeah.
I've known a few people.
Well,
yeah.
People that are vulnerable
never came back from.
No,
she never came back.
Dude.
I knew this one guy and don't want to
say it in college.
He used to just be the guy that would
always take 10 heads instead of a one
hit.
You're like,
dude,
just take one.
Hey Bro,
I'm taking attendance anyway.
Constantly doing that.
It's constantly doing.
I stopped talking to him because it was
just like hanging out with our retired.
He became a hippie.
Right.
And then I saw him like later,
like five years later,
and that dude was barely,
like,
he was not doing acid anymore,
but he,
his brain was so god that it was like
talking to a dumb,
like a mentally retarded person.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that's what they said happened.
And Ted Kaczynski,
like he was a part of the Harvard lsd
experiments.
They did.
Oh,
they unlocked them.
Fringe cooked people with lsd while he
went.
When he went to,
um,
I think he was teaching in the Pacific
Northwest,
I forget which,
uh,
where he was teaching,
but he went to,
um,
might have been San Francisco,
was at Berkeley,
might've been Berkeley.
Anyway,
he went there.
He taught for a long enough period of
time.
Yeah.
He taught for a long enough period of
time that he could store up enough money
to buy a cabin and then start his attack
on technology.
So the guy buys this fucking little
piece of land and this little tiny cabin
and goes up there and decides to start
assassinating people who were involved
in the creation of technology.
And this all came about because of the
LSD studies where they dosed this guy to
the gills.
There's a documentary,
it's a documentary about it called the
net and it's all about Ted Kaczynski.
Netflix probably,
probably,
I don't know.
Um,
I feel like it's a foreign film that's
subtitled,
the net unibomber it's probably a good
opportunity to say that shrimp fest is
August ninth,
10th and 11th this year.
Shrimp Festival.
You can get it on youtube if you want
to.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The full version is available on
youtube,
it's called the net,
the unabomber,
lsd and the Internet.
And um,
it's from 2003 and it's a German
documentary.
It's a,
it's about the raw.
It's fucking fascinating shit,
man.
Because if you see the actual story,
it really is pretty fascinating when you
find out like,
wait a minute,
what did they do to him tell us that he
was dosed up on,
on,
on Lsd.
Like,
oh,
ms dot lot more sense.
Yeah.
What did you guys do to that?
God,
did you guys create that guy?
Like this might have been something that
someone created.
You think about like what the unibomber
yeah,
that's legit.
Super Heroes.
Super.
Yeah,
he really is.
He's like,
like Samuel Jackson and unbreakable.
Right?
So that one,
he's like a real superhero,
bad guy.
Character.
Super Genius Guy who decides to live in
the woods as a recluse and attack
civilization from the outside.
Still going out there.
It's a good question.
I don't think you ever get away with not
paying something.
You can't just pay off all your taxes.
You can't say,
hey look,
I'm going to give you guys a million
dollars 30 years.
This is for the next 30 years of
property taxes were gone.
We don't have to talk anymore.
You can't do that.
I don't think they still take a piece of
you.
I think property taxes can change too.
That can't ever be free.
You can't ever just be like,
look,
I got my little thing.
That's true.
You can't ever be free.
It's kind of gross in it.
Had D of property taxes just hit me what
it was and I was like,
wait,
so you don't.
Even when you have something you don't
have it,
so if you don't pay it,
they'll just take back your shit.
You're just renting then just renting
everywhere.
Yeah.
You're renting everywhere you go and
ultimately when you die,
if you don't pay that property tax,
that's the reason why they use to close
it on your state.
They take 30 percent of it,
40 percent of it between there.
Every time you earned a dollar,
then they take eight to 10 percent.
When you spend that dollar and then when
you leave it to someone,
whatever the little you have left,
when you leave it to someone,
a friend or a family member,
they take half of that.
You know that when they spend it,
they took 10 more percent.
You know,
it's really legit though.
States that don't have state taxes.
You know,
if you live in Seattle,
you're in Washington state,
Delaware state taxes,
Florida.
There's quite a few.
Nevada,
Nevada is a big one.
No state taxes.
That's big.
Really Nice that that's 10 percent.
Vegas,
Nevada.
If you want to have an ecstasy,
hooker overload,
that's your spot.
You should go to fucking start your
podcast from the hard rock.
Whatever happened to that.
Why aren't you guys doing podcasts from
there?
Do a podcast from there from whatever
it's called,
the hangover or what's The Sunday thing
that they have?
Their Rehab Rehab.
We did one episode and then I guess
somebody high up that owned the banks
that own the place or solid and like,
hey,
we've been having so much problems with
other shows being on in there.
There was like some show that was a
reality show based there.
Oh yeah,
on the show they showed people like
doing cocaine and all this like hookers,
shit stuff and so I guess they got into
a lot of trouble for it and then so then
when we did our desk squad podcasts,
they're the bank saw the first episode
or heard about the first episode.
I was like,
wait,
what are you doing?
You're doing another reality show for a
guy that called desk squat and know is
that they accept it and then all these
people got fired.
It was hilarious.
I went there one time,
my bed bug and I smoke cigars,
drank,
did some ecstasy and man I was having a
good time until we actually got on the
plane later and I was like,
this was a horrible mistake.
I feel like I'm Vegas podcasts,
like a live vegas podcast could probably
be fucking crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
like do like not just live vegas shows
but do a live vegas podcast somewhere.
They'd have to be the right size venue
though.
Yeah.
Well you could have a legit podcast.
Is there anywhere in Vegas to go to go
out to party?
That's not just a loud nightclub where
they playing techno music,
Irish pubs and stuff in Vegas.
It's just A.
There's just people that live in Vegas
all year round.
They're there.
Yeah.
Go to the green door.
Was that,
that swingers club?
Not heard of that.
They just do a comedy show there.
Swingers club.
I heard this yesterday that somebody
gets a,
an STD to swingers club.
They all have it within a week.
They're all just fucking attorney.
Yeah.
Dirty little piglets.
Did you see Bill Clinton on?
Oh,
talking about aliens did.
What did he say about aliens?
Man.
Pretty sweet.
He was saying that,
um,
we could play it,
but it took.
Really didn't.
He didn't say much.
What he said was that he went and
looked,
uh,
when he first got into office,
he went and immediately went looking to
look into the friendly,
warm area.
Fifty one looking to Roswell crash,
look into all this different shit and
find out whatever he could.
That's cool.
And he said that if he did find alien,
she would tell us.
He goes,
yes,
I would,
I would.
And he said it and it seemed like he was
telling the truth,
but what does that mean?
I believe that when he sees a
charismatic relationships with that
woman,
no,
I just meant obviously I stuck a bit
fucking cigar in her vagina.
I meant or whatever and it wasn't actual
sex and like we didn't have a baby.
I didn't come into La.
So you weren't,
you didn't know you were lying to us.
You didn't know God?
Not by my definition of the term.
Not by my definition.
That's how he got out of it.
I forgot about that.
I'm like,
wow,
if he really knew about aliens,
I don't know if he would tell us,
but he might.
What's it got to lose now?
It's so cool.
That would be the dopest thing to check
too.
If you've got an office just for
personal inquiry,
like,
wait.
So I do tell us now.
Right?
Let's go.
Let's hear.
Who is the Illuminati?
Who's with the aliens?
Let's hear.
I want to.
I want to know like our JFK here.
Let's hear it.
Oh,
JFK got shot
because I want to know.
I'd want to know what has been going on.
They you do that sort of.
Sure.
To get Jimmy Kimmel's
question you asked him.
I would want to find out about us.
So you're getting in my second term,
we had the anniversary of Roswell.
You waited that long.
I did.
Well I did.
And then I,
there's also area 51.
You remember there was a great Scifi
movie where there was an alien kept deep
under the ground area.
Fifty one.
So first I had people go look at the
records on area 51 to make sure that
there was no alien down there.
I bought that because everybody who
works there has to stop about an hour
away and put on special clothing and
then drive in and out.
And that's because a lot of our stealth
technology is made there.
We know that now and,
and,
but there are no aliens there.
So then,
uh,
when the Roswell thing came up,
I knew we'd get,
you know,
the letters.
So I had all the Roswell papers reviewed
everything.
If you saw that there were aliens there,
would you tell us?
Yeah,
you would.
We know.
We know now we live in an ever expanding
universe.
We know that there are billions of stars
and planets literally out there and the
university is getting bigger.
We know from our fancy telescopes that
just in the last two years,
more than 20 planets had been identified
outside our solar system that seem to be
far enough away from their sons and
dense enough that they might be able to
support some form of live.
So it makes it increasingly less likely
that we're alone.
I want to get high with him yet.
And they,
I don't know,
but if we were visited someday,
I wouldn't be surprised.
I just hope that,
uh,
is not like independence day.
Yeah.
Right.
That it's a,
you know,
a,
a conflict.
Well now we have maybe the other way to
unite this increasingly divided world of
ours.
Yeah.
He actually had the same point that
Reagan had.
Remember Reagan had that speech and he
talked about.
I often wonder if we,
you know,
it was talking about an invasion from
another planet.
If we were invaded by another
planet,
would that be enough to join America
together,
joined the world together rather and
making us realize that we're all in this
together.
Do you think that some will do with they
have aliens and we're like,
Hey,
plan the tech make aliens.
That would unite people in a lot of
ways.
First of them versus if there was a real
alien invasion,
then what was that show with the lizard
tongues versus versus v.
that's it,
man.
If there really were aliens here,
if they're smart enough to get here,
they're smart enough to be running shit.
There really are aliens.
They're like in the banking industry and
really already here.
It's taken over.
They just decided to just run this
stupid government.
How we can control everything.
Oh,
it would they to do it for themselves
and just do an infiltrate the banking
business and control the entire planet.
Just from the controlling the resources
and the money is internet.
Where do we find out the internet?
It is analia home lives off people's
attention.
Well now it's super powerful.
Technology might be an alien.
How about that?
Technology might be an alien that forced
human beings to create it.
Technologies and alien that exists in an
idea existed in idea and the creativity
that infects human consciousness.
The human consciousness develops this
extraordinary ability to manipulate,
matter and change its environment and
then the human being accelerates it from
there so that this alien has come in the
form of an idea and that idea is just a
simple desire to improve upon your
surroundings and that in that desire it
in the ever x accelerating and
escalating nature of human beings that
this desire builds on the past
generations work and they build on that
past generations work and they keep
going on and on and on and
exponentially.
The group of people that understand the
technology gets bigger and bigger and
bigger,
and then finally,
boom.
It gives birth to whatever the fuck the
salient is.
This alien meaning this artificial
biological life that's created by
technology that just used the human
imagination to give birth to it so that
imagine if you send ideas and you sat.
An idea literally is an alien seed and
you drop an ID and a group of monkeys
and you know that in x amount of million
years they're going to build you.
Right?
Because that's just a natural progress.
Yeah.
Sort of like a caterpillar is naturally
going to become a butterfly.
If you drop the seats,
yeah,
there's going to be chaos.
There's going to be fucking crazy wars.
There's going to be battles.
It'd be nuclear weapons.
They'll be pollution.
There was,
but at the end of the day,
these dumb monkeys are eventually going
to give birth to you that you're going
to come out of it no matter what because
what you are is artificial intelligence
is plugged into the power of the
universe.
Artists,
you know,
artificial intelligence that requires a
biological being to make it.
But then once the biological being makes
it okay,
I got it from here,
and then you have porn and you come out
guns blazing and by the time that human
beings have choke themselves off the
earth now literally choke themselves
through to pump in their own shit into
the ocean and when you're okay because
you're there,
it doesn't matter because this
biological lifeforms unnecessary anyway,
because it's just a tool to create the
technological life.
And that's how it comes into a place.
And exactly.
I moved so slowly that so quickly with
them that it's like whatever.
So it'll only be a couple trillion
years.
Well it doesn't matter for them because
are infinite live forever,
will have a baby.
They just,
they just say,
look,
we'll just plant a seed.
It takes time to grow.
And that seed is his curiosity and
imagination and the ability to
manipulate their environment with their
fingers.
So they get in there and they start
fixing shit and changing it and fucking
boom and tightening things up and
clipping things off and lighting things
on fire and blowing things up and
pressing buttons.
And next thing you help this fucking
terminator steps out of a machine.
Did,
it just took awhile,
took a million years,
took a 100,000
years to just what has gestation period.
Yeah.
It's just what happens.
Sort of like,
um,
you know,
you've seen those,
uh,
those weird parasites that grow inside a
different insects bodies and they forced
the insect to do things to make them
hatch.
There's a grasshopper that gets affected
by this aquatic worm and it commits
suicide so that the worm could give
birth,
could give birth through its body.
That worm bursts out of its body in the
water.
Oh really?
So it actually wires the grasshoppers
brain and talks to grasshopper and
drowning itself.
So it can be born out of the water.
Yeah.
That's what lives his whole gestation
period out of the water that's going
into it.
Wow.
Yeah.
Lives inside a fucking grasp yet.
Biology.
So now why wouldn't anyone research that
shit and try to use it for a weapon?
Of course,
of course you should.
Of course they would.
And that in that acceleration,
it's like we,
if you think about Eylea,
what are,
what are we doing?
If we're doing that,
if we're giving birth to this
technology,
this technology literally is become a
part of our lives.
It's become a part of our bodies in the
sense that you have a phone connected to
your body at all times.
It's becoming more a part of your body.
When you start going with the Google
glass and these new ideas they have
about possible contact lenses.
The future that you can see screens that
only you can see,
you're gonna.
Be able to read all these things out
like you're going to be on a date,
you're going to see tech show up over
her eyelids and you're like,
bitch,
are you texting your friends?
No,
but you'll see a little bit.
Are you getting texts right now?
You have auto text on so people could
just text you while we were out at
dinner.
I'll text on,
take your lenses off.
I'm not taking my lenses off.
We'll then turn all of textile.
It's off or this thing they were doing
about whether or not safe to drive with
them and they were like,
you know,
it's gonna be distracted,
is going to be texting,
and we looked at directions and the guy
response was like,
it's actually way safer.
Like if you don't understand the
experience,
you're not like looking at it.
It's,
it's just part of your site.
It's definitely better than looking
down.
Yeah.
They used to have those things were.
So the speedometer it would up onto the.
Onto the,
like a windshield.
Yeah.
And so you'd see it.
So you could still be looking at the
road while they still have it.
That was pretty cool.
Yeah.
They have it still corvettes habit.
Really?
Yeah.
To exist in a lot of cars and car.
So you're not taking your eyes off the
road to use less,
but if you were texting,
what in your mind be off it?
Like if I can look right at you in my
mind wanders,
I don't even see you.
Let my mind wander or something else.
That's true.
It's definitely not as good as only
paying attention to the road.
And I see it all the time,
I'll see like someone weaving and you
look down and you see they're looking at
their phone and just like,
God dammit you fuckhead were even then
you're still keeping it out and you're
on the high way.
Like being on the highway and weaving
your phone is scary.
Should be more careful next time.
Yeah.
Next paragraph.
What are you going to say?
Yeah,
he's fucking people.
That's one thing that I think you really
should not do,
especially when you're on the God
texting and driving.
Yeah.
Fuck,
that's a scary thing.
I still do it though,
but I still do it.
Why don't you do a text thing,
like a,
um,
a voice to text thing.
You could do that,
but then you've got to open that.
Oh No.
They do it on the iphone system to do
that.
Didn't get it right though.
It's like,
come on.
Then you get all like delete it.
Start over.
This is being done through voice
recognition software because I'm not an
asshole.
So like pretty much close.
Yes.
Oh,
right next to me if you need
clarification.
Yeah.
The old everybody used to have a button
and send like real simple stuff.
I've tried for like a Siri read me the
new text and it says options replied or
whatever.
Ooh,
is it work?
But it's good to talk slowly.
But the,
the complaints about Siri are pretty
fucking profound.
Serious,
been fixed.
Then if say totally pretty awesome.
How awesome.
I love it.
I use it all the time that it's good for
weight.
Like simple things like Siri,
call my friend John or,
or Siri,
I need to go home.
You have to talk to.
You got to call her Siri first.
She listens better if you talked to her
that way.
Like I need,
I need to drive home and then,
you know,
it was say like you can choose.
Wait.
Yeah.
I think if you pointed to something like
Siri,
find me directions home.
Like if you talk to it more than that,
it reads and understands those verbs
better.
When you said I need to go home,
what did it say?
Okay,
here I need to drive home.
Getting directions to Brian Redman and
you're like,
no,
no worry.
Yeah.
And then it takes me right to,
you know,
driving directions
almost gave the line of freaks outside
your house.
It doesn't matter man.
I'll be walking to starbucks and people
tweet me photos of me walking now.
Fuck you.
Fuck you will leave you alone once you
realize it's no big deal.
Don't me that he goes,
why don't we read with your shirt off on
sunset and Rebecca,
because I don't give a fuck.
So I get.
Yeah.
So I'll get Mitch.
So,
um,
this trip is triumphant.
Return to tempe.
Was that symbolic in,
in any sort of a way?
Well,
I did think a little bit like that.
Like we used to go there with you.
That was one of the first stops we would
make happy.
That was pretty much every year.
Yeah,
that was a big one.
So it was like I did,
we did a phoenix in a up lie before,
which was like fine and good.
But this was like,
oh yeah,
this place.
That was one of the early,
like big clubs.
Yeah.
Also a thought love was like,
I'll never be able to headline that
club.
It's too big.
You know,
even if you go to 300 seater,
that place is 50 percent bigger than
that.
Yeah.
It's a big spot.
So,
so actually doing it and getting to pull
it off a little bit of that.
You know what?
You have to step back for a second.
Like how did you guys bring anybody
else's?
Just Youtube.
Polly.
Polly casinos opened for us who?
POLICA.
He just has these lives,
their lives.
So he would just do a few minutes and
then bring somebody up.
Yeah,
that's awesome man.
It's cool crowds.
He has a problem that I tell everybody
to opens for me.
I'm like,
just so you know,
a lot of them.
I mean a lot of them got highlight the
minute before the show started.
Yeah.
So don't.
If they're just like smiling for your
first time,
I just don't read into that.
Like you're doing fine.
Do you get him high Paul?
Yeah,
yeah,
he was,
I got the local Thai.
I try not to.
I try to like later in the week,
once I've gotten to know them,
then I have to impress me.
Get them high like you used to get me
like way too hot.
Do you,
uh,
do you impress upon them that it would
be good to get high before the show?
Yeah.
And then if I don't do that,
I'm like I let them be professional for
a show or two.
But then it's like,
come on bitch,
come on,
come on.
Just fine.
Just knowing they won't be,
but just like,
just do it.
Who Cares?
Just do it.
She's not even hit the owner.
Not even a year report.
I remember there was one lady in Tempe
that would be like call Dan Murphy's
because I had this Lasky,
had his fucking spies.
I brought a flask because you weren't
allowed to drink on stage.
We had to Brian's out the idea.
He goes,
well they won't give us alcohol.
How about we just go buy some alcohol?
And the Joe is like,
I'm rich.
That's right.
Let's go buy alcohol.
We went to the liquor store and brought
back whiskey,
vodka and flasks.
And then a green room is set up
perfectly because when you go in there's
a little alcove deep in there.
And to the left that you can't see from
the doorway.
And it became a joke on stage because I
pulled out the flask and I said I like
to take my diet coke and then I like to
pour like warm coconut,
like keep,
keep the warm coke and this thing just
heated up with my body.
That's right.
And then I can pour it in there.
See it's st color as coke.
And a lot of people think it's like
whiskey or something.
But that's crazy.
You're not allowed to drink whiskey on
stage,
so you keep getting cokes brought to you
on stage you were taking.
And the uh,
the waiter,
I'm like,
uh,
whoever it was,
waitress,
waiter ratted me out.
And so Dan called me up and he's like,
what are you actually drinking on that
stage?
And I said,
no,
it's a gag man.
I'm a professional.
Was I didn't even care if I was loud.
I was like,
listen,
dude I know is not a real law.
So cuts are made up of state law.
Yeah.
They made up a law to run this place.
Well,
the law was you weren't allowed to drink
on stage in a few years.
I was like,
what a weird law exist.
It was bullshit.
They made up a fake law because they
didn't want comics being comics.
But then when I was done,
once I went to the bar,
I could have a beer and I saw the box
and to look over my shoulder and I saw
he was looking at.
I was one of the owners and I was like,
dude,
I'm done.
Yeah,
I'm officers.
Give me the fucking beer.
Well,
look at them.
I'm a grown man.
Got All crazy.
They're just so frustrated here.
The tempo alcoholic drinks for you guys.
So I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
well when,
when that dude uh,
who,
uh,
owned it wouldn't let us have a shot
before the show.
I'm like,
listen man,
come on.
You're,
you're crazy.
Like you can't do this.
Like,
I know what I'm doing.
You don't think I know what I'm doing.
I'm not going to go off the rails here.
If I go off the rails,
you don't book me again.
I've never gone off the rails.
But here's the thing,
these people have gone off the rails,
not at a comedy club,
but I've never fucked up a weekend.
I've never gone in there and got drunk
on purpose and I bet we've all gone off
the rails trunk.
Okay.
That's not what I'm saying.
But I'm saying as a professional and I
think that if you're,
you know,
if you run into a comedy club,
you got to let comedian's comedian and
then if we're not good then don't invite
us back at that price.
We know what we're doing for the most
part.
And if not I do delete.
Shouldn't be in the content business.
I don't really like dirty.
I do this,
don't worry about it.
Yeah,
that's a big one.
They don't really like dirty thing like
oh come on,
you know.
And that's another thing too.
One time saw some open or through good
with 30 is a problem with a lot of these
guys that run these clubs that are like
in recovery.
And that was that guy.
He was a nice guy,
but he had an issue in the past with
alcohol and so he was very adamant that
alcohol is a bad thing and he's in
recovery and he's very religious and so
having us there just was kind of a crazy
thing in the first place and then having
us there and us wanting to drink,
so it wasn't the guy that that,
that not the crazy guys they got rid of,
but the next guy came in who turned out
to be like the more majority.
Then the other guy remember that they
will open up a new club in town and he
goes,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
this is my own company or,
and then all of a sudden then he just
disappeared.
Well,
didn't he have like a health problem?
Like a real bad health failure?
They found him dead.
They found him dead in the hotel.
I'll
failure bunch of low investors,
two week run.
When they said they hadn't heard from
him in a week and he was a goody two
shoes before.
I was like,
oh,
he's a suicide or something,
or a murderer.
He's gone.
Who knows?
Dawn,
let's not talk about it too much in the
air.
We don't want to be a part of it.
We want to make sure that we're going to
kill him back.
I'm going to be there.
We want to make sure we can keep going
to that club.
Part of the reason that I started some
investigation.
Oh right.
You think it's a straight up murder,
man.
You're on the record with.
Oh son of a bitch.
I see what you're doing.
I can't believe you.
I trusted you next.
I'm Rogan chronicles.
That was a place where we had years and
years of sets there.
I mean we,
I was doing so many crazy people.
That's one of the first place I open
there for Pauli once and it was like
first day of the weekend and so we doing
is merchant.
Some girl came up with like a t shirt,
big busty Asu.
So with like a teacher,
you know,
they cut their tee shirts.
She did that.
She goes,
hi,
really lecture set.
And I didn't know what it was back then,
but I got the tingling in your balls.
You know what it was.
I didn't know what that means.
Just say,
Hey,
what are you doing?
Like Oh,
let's hang out.
We should hang out.
So your spidey sense,
we're going off.
And you were like,
I just waited.
What's your signal?
Yeah,
I just waited and didn't ever ask and
she left.
I just thought she would eventually find
me,
but that was never going to happen.
Yeah,
that's highly unlikely.
God,
I let it go.
If that happened on a Saturday I'd be
able to handle it.
But on the Thursday or Wednesday,
that's what I'm saying,
Dawg.
Saturday you'd be like comfortable.
Still upset.
I have gotten hurt in that girl.
I guess she would've had herpes.
Maybe she wouldn't know,
but then it's just negative but I didn't
go for it.
You silly boy.
Have you had your man period lately?
No.
What's that?
And I have this theory that when we shit
and it's all bloody in there,
that it's possible that he does at the
same time,
like it's based on the moon.
How often do you guys?
Shit when you get your shit happens.
It happens every couple of months.
It goes for like a week week,
that week executives are the hemorrhoid
thing.
It has to be,
oh my God,
and then you wipe and you just like,
oh,
I'm still wiping a lot of shit.
Be like,
no.
It was just soaking red blood.
That's all die on your hand and go
straight through the toilet paper.
You guys both need to go to a doctor
together and find out what aliens are
raping you.
In the middle of that study,
do a fucking camera over your bed.
That's something really watched aliens
come into the room and take you through
the walls in the middle of the night.
Return you later.
It's sometimes when you stand up at your
toilet seat.
Looks like Dexter,
like the blood spots that you know.
We didn't go in the water.
If you have too low,
man,
if you guys are both shit out that much
blood pours out the warmth.
It's like a warm fuzzy.
It's like you take a girl and turn it
over real thin beaker and turn it over.
Like about that amount of.
This is not for the shock girls.
Those not that much water.
Not something to be proud of.
You guys are both.
Jamie,
are you okay?
Are you and I in the same boat?
I can tell you this though.
I did have a massive diarrhea problem
last week.
It was really worst diarrhea problem.
My problem was a long time.
I do not know multiple days or one
diarrhea in multiple days.
I don't know if it was a stomach cold.
I don't know if it was something that I
ate that didn't agree with me,
but it was like one day I had a headache
and my head I was like,
wow,
I feel so.
I think it's like a food poisoning issue
because I had a headache and I was like,
man,
I feel weak.
Terrible.
No,
definitely not.
Definitely for that.
Yeah,
it was.
Um,
no,
it,
it was post ham,
but I hadn't eaten the ham for days,
but it definitely wasn't that.
It was something that had had I think
that day or before that day anyways.
Diarrhea.
Oh my goodness.
I mean it was more than a week after I'd
eaten the Ham.
Now that I think about it,
did you mix it with the regular dump and
have like a no,
dude,
it was just this is what happened in
whatever was going on inside.
My stomach was converting everything I
ate into liquid and I didn't even make
sense.
It was like defined physics.
How solidified was it w?
It was water.
If you dropped it on a,
an inclined table at a 40 degree
incline.
Would it go straight off the table?
Take a minute to go to ride like a
fucking great wave through Ray Brown,
wave of destruction,
dude,
it would rumble.
My stomach would rumble and then I would
go,
oh shit,
and I'd have really bathroom.
Then I'd get to the and I would hold it
up and commercials like,
listen,
I wouldn't.
There's no way.
I was brave enough to fart.
There was no way.
There was no way because I would get
into that tub or get it out of the bowl
rather,
and it would just hear whoosh,
just just,
just water tub my ass.
Complete water for like two days and
then it became like very untrustworthy
shit for the fourth day and I got
hemorrhoids.
I had to go get preparation h oh no.
Squeezing it and pushing it.
Trying to get it to come out for so
long,
which is really bad.
Push air bubbles into your asshole.
Well,
I think squeezing your ass like that,
trying to poop is very bad for you.
You're not supposed to do that.
And that's apparently one of the things
that causes hemorrhoid long dumps.
So then.
But that preparation h is a motherfucker
too because one day have that cleared it
right up really,
really quick.
Get the cooling.
The cool ranch.
When are the cool ranch sense?
Smell refreshing.
Find out people are like putting it on
food.
You can eat that sir.
Tastes just like a preparation.
H management preparation.
H was totally edible.
Whatever it does it,
it really works.
Good at uh,
fixing any sort of a hemorrhoid
situation and got down there.
They went away like within a day.
But man for fucking days,
four days of totally untrustworthy
shits.
Drip.
The pasty shit where it's like you could
spread it on brick.
Oh,
I can spread it stuff.
Yeah,
it was like leaves in there and shit
because I still eat healthy,
but it was like a lot of liquid.
It was some sort of a stomach bug,
whatever it was.
Um,
I don't have any idea where it came from
food or whether it came from just
catching a cold and you know,
that this cold manifests itself as a
stomach bug,
but whatever it was,
man,
it was crazy for a few days and I felt
real weak.
Like I'd go to pull my bow back and it
was kind of difficult to pull the bow
back because you're weak from stumping.
Yeah.
And people use it that I was weak.
I was weak.
Like I would like pick things from not
having it.
Yeah,
I could feel it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Definitely dehydrated.
But also just I wasn't eating right.
Like I scared no,
I wasn't getting hungry either.
I mean I was eating bright in that I was
having like lettuce and salads and stuff
like that,
but I wasn't eating very much.
I wasn't eating like a light meals
during the day because my stomach was so
untrustworthy.
Is that when that happened with
diarrhea?
What is it?
What's happening?
I don't know man,
but whatever it was just adjusting.
It's just too much.
I would eat like a steak.
I would have steak and some salad and it
would turn into water.
How to stake in a salad become.
I mean my,
my body was liquefying it and it would
come out just whoa.
What is that?
That's too much stomach acid.
That just breaking down everything and I
don't know the,
the,
the process.
I should probably know that shit on your
hand a little bit.
Sort of smelled it.
Right.
And see if there's some on it.
Enzymes on enzymes.
It's all been a dietician on it.
That's how it got me out of it.
I just had to do the time.
I just had to let my body process at
times.
You just drink a lot of water.
Put in the reps?
Yeah,
it was.
I was definitely thinking that I was
probably getting dehydrated from.
I was like,
so much water's coming out of my ass,
like I better make sure I drink a lot to
go with it.
All right.
Does your hemorrhoid when it happens,
do you even feel the hemorrhage?
Because I still feel that.
I feel like it's like,
oh,
I still have.
There's still some stuff I gotta wipe
off really?
Like oh,
that's just not just my mind.
Just a little while my bleeds because
like a giant of that's just my ass now.
That's my shit right there.
It feels like what leads out?
It doesn't even feel anything.
It just lets that will.
That exploded inside,
isn't it?
Anyway,
inside.
I don't even feel it.
Mindset.
Mine's on the rest of their diet that
you can take.
That stops that from happening.
I probably stopped finding foods broken.
Jack's lodge up inside your anal binding
foods.
Stay away from them or you eat a lot of
them.
I forget what it is.
Oh,
well you should probably know.
It's one of those two.
So rice was in that group.
Binding food,
eat or dale away from them or keep eat.
A lot of them don't really go by the
regimen,
but if you do do that,
it would help prevent hemorrhoids.
Um,
yes,
that's my doctors don't where they got
it.
And um,
that's the 19th to eat a lot of solid
research.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Does that help at all?
I don't know.
I feel like it makes you ship more
often.
Yeah.
But if you,
um,
if you doesn't it come out like we need
a lot of salads.
It comes out real easy.
Woo.
Oh,
right.
Yeah,
that's,
I guess the scraping,
pushing.
I used to pray it was so jacket.
Who'd be so jacket?
She claimed that I prayed to have come
out because it hurts so bad.
Oh,
that's horrible.
That was just so inflamed in there
because I was just wasn't dumping
because I knew it'd be bad.
So I was like,
let me hold it for another few days.
Oh my God.
Days of dumping compact.
You held off from days.
We could have fun.
That's insane.
Shit.
Every week.
Dude.
That is so insane.
That's so insane.
I've never even heard that's toxic.
I guess for sure.
You're containing all that stuff in your
body that's supposed to be evacuated.
Well,
it's in that spot.
Whatever that spot is.
Not Rubber hit fucking fill up dump,
but it will become too big for my log.
So separate.
It's like your first time.
No,
no,
no.
Your first time doing anal.
You Fuck Mandingo.
It's like,
that's pretty much what it was my
asshole.
And it was probably all dried up in
there.
Right up.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Peace.
Jaggedy chunks tearing you apart as you.
Shit.
I would have to reach and sometimes in
terror.
Oh,
you had to do that dog had to get a
castrated them.
Yeah.
Johnny,
I need his balls removed because two
things.
One,
he had an inflated prostate that was
pressing up against his colon and it was
making them constipated and he was uh,
in the,
in the hospital for a over a week.
I had to bring them in and they had to
try to figure out how to get him to
deprecate because his,
that it was backed up and then they
found out the devastation was backed up
because he was like,
he would like go to [inaudible],
but then he wouldn't,
he would get on like Fan Dover crouched,
but he couldn't poop and I knew there
was something wrong.
So I brought him in and they found out
that it was,
his prostate was enlarged and you know,
he's an older male dog.
He's like seven now.
And so,
um,
I got them fixed.
So they take his testicles way,
which makes the prostate decreased to
then you've got room to shoot it up.
Yeah,
I used to,
but some people say that,
you know,
you should,
uh,
you should get a dog fixed and it's
like,
it's healthier and happier for the dog.
But I had a veterinarian didn't agree
with that at all.
He said it's totally natural for that
animal to have its testicles.
He goes,
if the dog is,
if you,
you don't want them to breed and is a
female around,
get the female fixed and it goes and if
you want to get the dog fixed you can,
but you don't have to get the dark fix.
And he's like,
if you're not,
you're not making your dog a dad,
like forcing your dog to have to breed
and make unwanted puppies.
If you're not being irresponsible with
the dogs.
Sexuality,
like you don't have to get the dog.
Can you just get into the secondary one?
If it cut the balls off,
let it still fuck doggy condoms.
Yeah.
Because you don't want that.
You don't want that swelling.
It's the swelling that comes from the,
uh,
the testicles and the,
the enlargement of the prostate that
happens as they get older and that can
be alleviated by castrating the dog.
So the people get that.
I don't know.
I'm sure they do.
Humans were like,
I'm done fucking 72,
you know,
just come into my balls off.
I'm sure people do.
I'm sure there's people who have done
that.
I'm sure there's people who have just
been tired of being a prisoner to their
cock and balls and just fucking son of a
bitch.
You run me for the last time.
We're done.
Hold them in your hand for sure.
People have done that.
Cut your balls off.
Oh yeah.
People have done it with rubber bands.
The Maori tribe was big into that.
That's how you showed up.
Might by cutting your bolts off in front
of people.
Oh my God.
That's the dumbest thing I've ever
heard.
Oh,
that's why they didn't take over the
world.
Maybe that can't be true.
I just made it up,
but it was like you son
of a bitch.
Yeah,
they're.
They're fierce warriors.
They know the power of the balls.
They wouldn't cut the balls off like
they do tattoo their faces.
That's what I tell you about goofing off
over there.
Giggling and laughing and distracting.
I'm looking at your.
The message board and people are posting
tweets of his poops.
Once you pooped in awhile,
just have your pool.
Let's see.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to show some of the notable
ones.
Really notable ones,
you eat too many gummy bears and I
pooped and there was just like river of
like red inside the poop.
It was a massive poop.
Just running red in light but like so
thick.
Do you know you're addicted to sugar,
right?
Yeah.
You know about all that?
I do know it shouldn't be sold in places
you need to stop drinking and eating it
and chewing on it,
but no,
we need to get to the source.
And why is it addictive?
Substance just allowed to be in front of
children.
Habits out of it.
I agree.
In some ways they make laws about
cigarettes because I know it's so
damaging because not supposed to have
that before.
Until you're 18,
I'll sugar because it's delicious and
you've ruined.
Ruined kids.
Good time.
I Guess Sugar and candy and I says
because in my day it wasn't done that
way.
Hey,
I'm addicted now.
I'm an adult.
You look at an addict.
No,
you are.
I know you are.
I've seen you chew that candy.
Eat that gum,
not fat metabolism and are watching my
weight.
He got for awhile.
Are you lost a bunch of weight at one
time?
Right?
How much you lose?
Two pounds.
Fifty or 60 pounds.
That's amazing.
I was to 40.
What'd you do to lose it?
Just say healthy.
Just decided.
All right.
Enough for this.
Well,
I said I used to do these personal
challenges for myself.
Like uh,
the first year of college we've got our
report card we got are not online,
just like gave it to us.
So I see.
I see if I could go for a week just
leaving it in my pocket with me without
checking it.
You know,
you really want to know your grades.
Just these tests.
Ooh,
I liked that.
Yeah.
I went a week without lying.
Trying not to lie at all.
Whoa.
Got thrown out of the deployment.
Just do it.
It's so difficult.
Why?
I mean zero tolerance truck.
See it.
It's just.
I mean,
you don't go a day without lying
multiple times.
That's interesting.
I never even thought of.
So I had this problem when I took,
I took the journalism entry school.
You have to take a typing test and will
be at 25 words a minute.
I just got back from Israel so I hadn't
really tight much.
I was at 21,
22,
took it twice,
couldn't get it.
So I got my roommate,
my jumper,
Asian roommate,
and he was like,
Hey,
take the test for me.
Here's my alternative is my social
security number from.
I don't do that good.
But he's got like 65 words a minute.
Yeah.
So when I went to register for a
journalism class that next year,
they're like,
hey,
how come there's a block there?
Just want to know what you go from like
20 words a minute to like 65.
And it was like,
because I had someone check the test for
me and they're like,
what?
You were fucking around the first time.
And I was like,
no.
I had someone take the test for me who
was better than me.
Like you can't ever come to this.
The journalism like you're out forever.
Forever.
Try not line for a week.
You saw the pitch?
Yes.
Wait,
what did I say in the beginning?
What was the thing I do for personal
challenges?
Yeah,
but what was the food dropping weight?
Oh yeah.
So I just saw if I could eat healthy for
a week and I meant like note,
note sodium,
low sodium foods to.
But I just shattered pounds.
Just sort of like,
you know,
meat,
beef,
little things.
Just,
you know,
what healthy is?
Eat the healthy stuff.
Yeah.
You know what that is.
Storefront.
I don't be like,
well it's got some soy sauce.
Just keep fucking,
you know what healthy is so nonspecific,
so it's not healthy,
you know,
non.
Totally nonspecific.
You didn't just stay healthy.
Dropped a shitload of weight.
Now I must have a high metabolism to do.
Eat a lot of candy.
I do a lot of junk food.
I'll have a nice meal during the day and
then at night I'll go nuts.
And what kind of exercise you do and
these days,
a lot of walking around,
some hiking.
I went on some hiking in Phoenix on a
mountain,
walked all the way up,
made an instagram collide.
Yeah man.
Like a real chip does.
How did you instagram collages?
Fixed dish?
It's a new programs and new APP.
You just,
there's not even new making collages
like chicks because I want to do an
instagram picture,
but no,
no one picture looking now joe,
he's scratching,
stitch fix stitch and then it just makes
you feel what you're saying.
I see s,
T I C H O.
Okay.
Pic Stitch your stitching pick six.
Stitch.
Yeah.
And they have all these different.
Um,
you can do four pictures altogether.
All different templates.
Hilarious.
You're a girl with her up in New York.
Did that to,
you know,
I did that in Switzerland when I was.
Oh yeah.
I guess I was after a just outdoorsy
stuff.
Looks really good in New York.
New York has its very specific accents.
Right.
Have you ever noticed that like tech
people have sort of their own accent?
Interesting from speaking the same
language all the time?
Yes.
Then there's a thing,
there's a kind of thing that they do,
you know,
this sort of silicon valley,
they all talk like the downstairs
neighbors from,
uh,
from uh,
moving on up what's really cool times
they all have.
This is a weird sort of aspect to the
way they talk.
It's very tech like he's like,
this is like a very like specific sort
of Jefferson downstairs white neighbor
from the Jeffersons.
That's how they talk.
Yeah.
Palo Alto.
It was a very like up,
not like a pot pitched,
but just like uppity.
I was listening to these two guys that
were tech guys talking about this House
that this one guy was buying and you
know,
they were talking like mortgages and
interest rates and all this different
shit,
but they were talking like in Techie guy
accents and I was like thinking.
I was like,
I guarantee you these guys are involved
in some way in technology,
some in some way or a part of it in some
way and then they start talking about
their job and they weren't.
They were,
yeah.
Yeah.
Me and Palo Alto,
the people just looked different.
They carry themselves differently.
Biking around,
I'll just different.
Well,
there they're definitely,
there's some really fucking smart
people.
Really smart and the amount of money
that it costs to live up there with
Xeloda.
All the houses were like,
what would it cost to live here?
And then just like saw,
I want to see a regular house and it's
$3.
Million to million.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's a regular house story house
that's supposed to be $400,000.
It's not supposed to be 3 million.
Like you're crazy.
That can't be that much money.
That doesn't make any sense.
The whole house,
all the electricity runs off.
They're like breaths.
Anti-Tech protesters invade Kevin Rosa,
San Francisco neighborhood.
Kevin rose parasite.
Who's cutting road?
How is he a parasite?
Yeah.
These people in his neighborhood,
they're not fans of Kevin rose and it
was Kevin rose.
Kevin rose is the creator of dig a or
where the creators,
a dig tech,
techie guy revision all of that stuff.
Screening.
What are they saying?
What's their argument against him?
Uh,
this is the letter.
It says,
greetings your neighbor at Blah Blah,
blah is a man named Kevin Rose sees a
parasite to her.
Prenupt perhaps not a view,
but of us.
This is why we're here to reveal it for
him.
And you're saying that he's a partner.
Capitalists at Google ventures.
Kevin directs the flow of capital from
Google into the tech startup bubble that
is destroying San Francisco,
so it's against technology
startups that he funds.
I can't read this.
They make more money.
What is it?
It's just so blurry.
Yeah.
A W says,
bring the swarms of young entrepreneurs
that have ravaged the landscapes of San
Francisco and Oakland.
Okay,
so it's.
It's anti the young smart people that
have money.
Yeah.
Let's look at this line four times a.
We are the ones who serve them coffee,
deliver their food,
suck their cock.
Wow.
Laura's.
Nearly all of them are just like Kevin
rose and we're tired of this miserable
and the city
suck their cocks.
They put suck their cocks in it.
Yep.
That's hilarious.
That is funny.
So even their fucking protesters were
smarter.
San Francisco is such a great place.
Definitely need to figure out a way to
keep the diversity,
etc.
That we need to solve.
Rising runs.
CuTe.
Sepa,
san francisco's and crackdown on
landlords booting folks out.
Oh yeah,
they do because all the cool
neighborhoods now,
there's so much money.
They're like,
well we can charge more and get rid of.
And so they have the gentrification,
which just means white people are here
now.
Um,
I now know like they don't have that
degenerate feel anymore.
The hate of just doing what you want.
Yeah.
I,
I find it fascinating.
Just as a,
a natuRal event was the same way.
You can't find a place in williamsburg
to rent.
it used to be like the thing you did
because it was like cool,
but now it's like rents are too high.
Everyone knew where he got out.
Isn't that fascinating though?
It's fascinating when things like that
happen,
like when you see a house like in san
francisco and it's $3,000,000,000
and you go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And then you try to figure out what are
you getting out of this 3 million bucks
location.
That's it.
Like that house is not a god damn 3
million downloads to somewhere else
beCause they'll want to go somewhere
else and it moves like the way deserts
move over,
like high speed of of years.
A year or Second.
Cisco's fucking great though,
man.
It is a great pretty cool city.
The people are cool as fuck I,
I really appreciate it up there a lot.
He iS cold.
We love seeing everybody with us.
San Francisco hoodies that they're all
buying because everybody gets there and
it.
It'll be warm and I'm warm.
You're right by the ocean.
It can be fucking brutal.
It's more than that.
It's cold.
What's the wet?
That's all it is because it doesn't get
cold like Alaska cold.
It gets cold.
It gets way colder than santa monica.
Yeah.
It gets into that.
It snowed when I lived there.
They say october is the only warm month,
but it was only once but it's node.
Um,
yeah.
I can't.
It gets,
you know,
even when it's summertime sometimes it's
good.
I went from june or july and it was
like,
it warms up a little bit during the day
and then cold.
But if you just live like a half hour
away,
you like five,
10 degrees warmer.
Yeah,
it's weird.
San francisco is just some strange
valley here.
Right over the hill.
I mean you drive 15 minutes and it's 25
degrees hotter or.
Yeah.
Or going the opposite.
Going to malibu.
Nice.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I understand it.
It worked.
People complain about the heat.
I'm like,
it was like 80,
like fucking where you live.
Yeah.
You were in hollywood unbearable.
You're catching the breeze off the
ocean.
Still still cool and stuff off.
That's where I live in west la too,
is even closer that breeze off the
ocean.
So nice man.
The other day,
um,
I was coming home from the airport and
the traffic is bad,
so I decided to take a take the pch.
I just started to get off of the highway
and just take some street roads.
I tOok the pch over near malibu and I
was like,
god damn,
it's beautiful here.
I always wonder if I could live there
though.
You don't have that dispensers nonstop.
Like I'm living so close to the ocean
and then one day that earthquake tsunami
thing kind of just tear me up.
That's one way to look at it,
but I mean,
look,
let's be honest.
If the slept with both those earthworks.
If the big earthquake happens right now
while we're in the studio,
we're kind of fucked.
you know,
most of the time you're driving away
from your house or you're not at home
when you're somewhere else.
You'd want to be on a cliff.
We definitely don't want to be near the
water.
You don't want to be near the water.
You might be wanting to be on a cliff
better than you want to be on the wall
and hope it goes inland.
ended up malibu creek state park,
like a camping area is beautiful and
just once you get over that first
mountain wilderness,
unbelievable.
That's orange.
It's really beautiful.
Yeah,
but I don't know if it's like a
convenient place to live and there's a
lot of flaky people that bring their
dogs everywhere in malibu.
oh really?
Is that thing going on where you go to a
restaurant?
People bring their dogs in.
What's going on?
I know there is,
but I know when you walked on the beach,
everyone just nods and smiles at each
other.
Like doing well.
Right.
You're too young.
You're in malibu.
Even if could just visiting and doing
great.
I hadn't been to santa barbara,
santa barbara.
Sweet.
Oh,
there.
I'm there in santa barbara.
uh,
May 2nd.
I'm at the lobero theater with joey
diaz.
Um,
yeah,
it's far,
but it's only an hour from like say,
um,
if you went from calabasas it would take
about an hour.
IT takes about an hour to get there.
Drive at night,
super fast.
If you went from la and it's great,
but when you go like,
oh,
let's go to the beach right now.
It's nice out like fucking hour 10.
Yeah.
From hollywood.
May second and lobero theater.
I'm kind of from a couple of days.
There's a few tickets left,
I think.
Not much.
Santa barbara,
you never played there.
Played there before.
Me and duncan and joey did it last year
or two years ago.
Used to be one of those runs those gigs.
I know he gonzalez would have quality
for the dollars.
It's a great town.
The town of santa barbara.
It's a great town through the grapevine
that got there at montecito.
Montecito is incredible.
all those old houses.
Old town santa barbara.
Yeah.
That's all cool.
It's dope.
At the beginning of the fighters to
refineries,
I said vineries wineries,
wineries are vineries whatever they are.
Yeah.
Just past that.
Like soul vein.
Yeah.
That's not too far out.
Then After that.
Right.
And how far solving?
It's about 30 minutes past that.
It's a nice area man who love it up
there,
you know,
san luis obispo.
You ever go there?
Small town,
college town,
but it's great.
Really cool place.
Like the opposite of that.
Yeah,
it's real.
It's where a chocolate dell grew up.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's where he,
uh,
went to college.
Shouldn't say grew up.
I don't know if he grew up there.
We went to college there,
but uh,
in what?
Where's san luis obispo?
But it's about another hour plus past
santa barbara know along the way to san
francisco,
which is a great a comedy festival
there.
Know san luis obispo comedy festival.
Easily slow fest.
Like who did that?
Who put that together?
I think maybe christian spicer,
maybe somebody else.
It's a small one,
but it's.
They do whatever here.
It's been like three or four years.
They get good comments if you done it
[inaudible] it's a little like the
comments a little like below.
Below that.
That's interesting.
And what do they perform in the theater?
They just gigs around,
you know?
Okay.
Like little clubs or something like
whoever.
Like a lot of times it's festivals like
portland.
Does it have to like venues will be
like,
or austin too.
They're like,
we'll let our bar code to use for this.
Right.
That's cool idea.
Idea of comedy festivals are fun,
man.
I mean I just did this one in south
beach and it was comedy central,
put it together and I'd done it once
before was guerra.
And the really cool thing about it
though is just the hang with all the
other comics,
you know,
benson was the,
we hang out with,
had align with the comment I'm doing
just for the,
it's like that hotel later.
It's like all just us hanging out moon.
Terribly cool.
Same reason.
Yeah.
That's the big part about it is like
comedians convention giving to do.
No one has a meeting.
No one has anything.
Yeah.
So let's all just go to the wash off and
have some fun and obliterated late at
night and everyone is so it does not
matter.
Indeed.
Alright,
you fucks.
Can I promoter a couple of days.
What do you got?
Well,
for 20 I got my store 20 show at the
comedy store.
It's a bunch of different things.
Maybe brian went through a video but
yeah,
it's daytime.
Oh,
I was kept looking at where I'm going to
be for foUr 20.
I'm like la,
la,
la and do It inside during the day.
The comedy store.
I like it.
Yeah.
Cops are gonna infiltrate maybe central
legal there.
And then uh,
edmonton and minneapolis check my
website already.
The great.com
and the storyteller shows on tuesday.
Yeah,
tuesday at the improv in hollywood.
Brian,
what do you got going on?
Uh,
April 18th,
portland,
Oregon with a tony hinchcliffe and
tiffany haddish at the funhouse lounge.
April 19th,
seattle,
Washington at the high line.
April 20th,
vancouver at the edgewater casino.
And then a tuscan and phoenix at the end
of april with sam aaa and polly
northwest comedy.
It's where you have.
Yep.
What did you say?
Tuscan what?
Uh,
in a tuscan,
Arizona,
I'm going to be there with same tripoli
and poly.
And then pauly shore.
You're doing paul.
He pushed the guy that he went,
a red phoenix,
tucson comic at some places.
Have you guys heard of Chile bombers and
phoenix someplace in Chile?
Bombers and.
Right.
Okay.
A desk [inaudible] dot tv for uh,
for those dates.
And uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to squarespace.com.
Go to squarespace.com.
And use the code word joe.
Save yourself some cash.
Thanks also to stamps.com
stamps.com.
Use the code wordj r e,
is that right?
About squarespace?
That's what it is right up my podcast.
Ari shapiro skeptic thing.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
yeah.
It's entered the code word joe for 10
percent off your first purchase.
Uh,
and uh,
jr.
He is the code for stamps.com.
And on it is the code for [inaudible]
dot com.
O n n I t save 10 percent off any and
all supplements.
All right.
See you soon.
Much love big kiss one
the.